an
Exzellent, auf gehts. Und bei mir war das Wlan schon kaputt. Zumindest im Erdgeschoss,
weil einfach random ein Ubiquiti Access Point abgekackt ist, der ältere von beiden. Einfach
aus, also zumindest nicht mehr erreichbar, keine Ahnung. Aber was wie immer geholfen hat,
Strom raus, Strom rein, geht wieder. Es ist eh erstaunlich, wieviel Probleme sich durch
Reboot lösen lassen. Also, der beste Reboot war mal, als mein Kühlschrank komische Geräusche
gemacht hat und ich hab den Strom vom Kühlschrank rausgezogen, wieder rein gemacht, die komischen
Geräusche waren weg. Ich weiß bis heute nicht, warum. Vielleicht hat sich irgendwas gelöst
dadurch, keine Ahnung. Aber es ist merkwürdig, dass Reboot auch beim Kühlschrank hilft.
Wann kommt der Trailer zu Battlefield 6? Ich denke mal, erstes Quartal ist Januar, Februar,
März. Ich denke mal Anfang zweiter Quartal oder so was. Oder Ende erstes Quartal, also
so im April oder... Januar, Februar, März, April, Mai. Ja, so im April oder so. Denke
ich mal. Ich meine, wenn die das wirklich Ende des Jahres rausbringen wollen, dann müssen
die jetzt ja dann so in dem Thema was zeigen. Irgendwelche großartigen Game-Shows oder sonstige
Geschichten, also von Gamescom zu E3 zu sonst was, ist fraglich, ob das dieses Jahr großartig
was geben wird. Gucken. Ich bin mal gespannt, in welchem Zustand Battlefield 6 dann rauskommt.
Wahrscheinlich total pipiger, kaputt. Excellent, excellent.
Übrigens, das Salami-Emote ist nicht das einzige, was entfernt wurde. Ich war gestern
bei einem Mario64-Runner im Chat und da wurden auch Emotes entfernt und der hatte als Emote
Polish drin. Das war ein Emote, wo einer seinen Sein vom Bett den Pfosten poliert.
Halt wirklich, wortwörtlich, mit einem Tuch den Pfosten vom Bett poliert. Und das war
halt auch etwas anstößig gefilmt. Das haben sie auch entfernt. Sicher ist da gar nichts.
Und glauben bringt ja schon mal gar nichts. Ich werde es mir nicht vorbestellen oder
so ein Blödsinn. Vorbestellen, ich bin da total skeptisch dagegen. Was willst du denn
erwarten nach den letzten paar Teilen und das im Prinzip kaum noch einer der Leute,
die wissen, wie man gescheites Battlefield macht dabei ist. Also jeder, der da nicht
skeptisch ist, der will sich hypen lassen und Geld ausgeben. Nee, nee, also dran glauben
bringt ja auch schon mal gar nichts. Ja, also 128 Spieler klingt, weiß ich nicht, ob das
so schlimm ist. Also ich finde, das ist gar nicht mal so schlimm. Das kommt auf die Maps
an, wie das Game gemacht ist. Ich überlege gerade, also das letzte Mal, wo ich so richtig
gehyped von einem Game war, also wo ich dann auch, also wo ich mich, wo ich mich noch,
wo ich mich noch richtig gut dran erinnern kann, ist Modern Warfare 2. Da war ich gerade
auf irgendeiner, das war eine Cisco-Schulung oder so war das glaube ich noch. Das war eine
Wanne, wann kam das raus? 2012? Nee, 2010? 2009? Okay, ja 2009. Da war ich gerade auf
irgendeiner Cisco-Schulung, das weiß ich, da war ich sonst wo, da war ich nicht daheim.
Samstags war das auch. Und da habe ich quasi permanent mit dem, mit dem, mit dem Frazier
Message geschickt und gelabert und so, wie geil, weil er hatte das Game schon, alter wie
ist das Game, erzähl mal so geil. Und danke für den Sam Schiffery Live, huge subscription.
Da haben wir dann quasi einen halben Tag, obwohl Schulung war, quasi telefoniert, wie, wie
geil MW2 ist. Also das war das letzte Mal, das war das letzte Mal, wo ich so richtig
krass, also so, so ohne Sinn und Verstand gehypt war auf einem Game. Und es gab sicherlich
die anderen Games, wo ich mich richtig drauf gefreut habe, also so, so komplett sinnlos
gehypt war ich glaube ich zuletzt auf MW2 und, und, und wahrscheinlich auch Black Ops
1. Warte mal, was kam zuerst? Nee, MW2 kam zuerst, ne? Genau. Ja, Armored Kill ist was,
das lässt sich wirklich nur gut spielen auf den Venice-Servern, wenn die, wenn die 100
Spieler haben. Das Problem ist nur, das Venice ist dead. Guck mal, guck mal. Keck wait, keck
wait. Ich mein es ist Sonntagvormittag, wenn da nicht Leute spielen weiß ich auch nicht,
ja? Also pass mal auf, pass mal auf. Entweder gar kein Server voll oder ein Server mit 20
Spielern. Wartet mal, pass mal auf. Ja, die haben ne Memory League, richtig fail, richtig
fail des Crash nach 5 Runden, ja ich weiß, weiß, hatte ich auch schon. Ey guck mal im
letzten Video ist da auch gecrashed, in meinem letzten Video ist, ist gecrashed wegen dem,
wegen dem, wegen dem, weiß nicht, was sie da veranstaltet haben, am Anfang ging es.
Vor allem, ganz ehrlich, ich versteh, ich versteh es warum, warum es ist, im Prinzip
ist es so, alter. So, wie ich von Anfang an gesagt hab, wenn du den Leuten keine konsistenten
Server oder halt so ein paar Aushängeschilder bietest, dann bringt das, bringt das nix. Ja,
und deswegen, und deswegen ist, ist dead. Aber du hättest auch ein bisschen mehr die
Werbetrommeln rühren müssen und vor allem, diese Memory League Geschichte, das kann ja
auch nicht sein, dass das da jetzt irgendwie 2 Wochen drin ist oder so. Vielleicht haben
wir auch keinen Bock mehr drauf, ich weiß es nicht. In Venice ist ein Krypto Miner drin.
Hm, weiß ich nicht. Das kann ich mir ehrlich gesagt nicht vorstellen, weil Krypto Miner
müssten ja eigentlich ordentlich, ordentlich CPU-Lass verursachen und das Ding verursacht
man. Naja. Ey, wo hast du das denn her, das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Mal ganz davon abgesehen, bei den Spielzahlen, ich geh mal davon aus, das meint ihr auch
nur, wenn man startet, weil ansonsten wär das doch ein bisschen, falls sie da irgendwas
im Hintergrund haben, werden das natürlich doch ein bisschen sehr, sehr, sehr wenig,
ja. Also hier im Hintergrund auch nix, aber selbst wenn, selbst wenn du da startest, dann
wird es denen ja mal absolut gar nichts bringen, gerade bei 5 Spielern. Also das kann ich mir
nicht vorstellen. Zumal die es ja auch geschafft haben von allen möglichen Seiten gewidelistet
zu werden und so. Naja. Mal gucken. Alter, ich hab irgendwas im Hals, was ist denn heute
los? Ja, ja, ja kannst du mal Bescheid sagen im Discord, würde mich interessieren, aber
ich kann es mir nicht vorstellen. So.
Okay, auf geht's, also. Naja, es ist ja nicht so, als wenn Games absichtlich verkackt, guck
dir Anthem an. Guck dir Anthem an, also die verhauen ja keine Games absichtlich, die denken
immer so, machen was Geiles. Zumindest die Stonks Leute. Also nur, dass sie sich das
nicht leisten können, ist keine Garantie dafür, dass da ein gescheites Game dabei rauskommt.
Ich würde sogar eher sagen, im Gegenteil, dann ist man noch mehr auf Stonks und Money
fokussiert, wenn man sich nicht mehr leisten kann als statt auf ein gescheites Game. Genau.
Das wichtigste ist, ordentliche Spielmodus und gescheite Maps. Das ist ja letztendlich
das, was Battlefield, also die wichtigsten Sachen erstmal. Die müssen nicht 50 Milliarden
Spielmodi rein machen, einfach ein gescheites Rush, ein gescheites Conquest und gescheite
Maps. So. Und das ist einfacher gesagt, als getan, weil das so ziemlich das Schwierigste
sein dürfte. Der Rest können sie eigentlich bewährte Battlefield-Kost reinpappen. Was,
ihr habt euch Vodafone-Shops angeguckt, was sagt ihr? Agile Coach. Ah, excellent, excellent.
Nehme ich mir vielleicht mal, das nehme ich mir vielleicht mal fürs nächste Stellenanzeigenvideo.
Bring es als nächstes mal ich ein Video über Windows XP, habe ich mir überlegt. Ich
habe es ja letztes Mal versucht, auf neue Hardware zu installieren, hat ja halbwegs funktioniert.
Und muss man mal wieder ein bisschen Oldschool-Geschichten machen. Und weil ich weiß nicht, ob es das
nächste Video ist, aber vielleicht eines der nächsten Videos auf jeden Fall. Ich müsste
mal wieder ein gamingbezogenes Video machen, aber aktuell passiert ja nichts Spannendes.
Battlefield ist ultra langweilig, Path of Exile interessiert zumindest auf YouTube keinen,
bei mir der guckt. Ja und ansonsten, was soll ich großartig zur aktuellen Gaming-Lage erzählen,
was nicht schon tausendmal durchgekaut wurde, ne? Vodafone schreibt sehr viel aus alles
Hyper Agile, ja sieht es sich gleich. Agile Coach, was macht man denn bei einem agilen
Coach? Macht man dann irgendwelche Yoga-Übungen oder was? Und willst Treiber der digitalen
und agilen Transformationen, ach du große Scheiße. Du förderst ein agiles Mindset und
eine Offen, ach du großartig. Im Prinzip braucht man so jemand, wenn das Unternehmen an sich
absolut nicht agil ist und man die Leute dazu zwingen muss, obwohl das Umfeld nicht dazu
passt. Ich bin ja der Meinung, wenn das Umfeld passt, ja, also wenn man den Leuten auch mal
ein bisschen Verantwortung lässt, wenn man die Leute auch mal selbst entscheiden lässt,
was sie wie machen, was wie wann wo gemacht wird, wie was angepasst wird, wenn nicht
so viel Business und Stonks ist, dann kommt die Agilität von alleine, weil man muss mal
gucken, wenn man mal so 2007, 2008 guckt, also so die Zeit, wo im Prinzip Admins noch
mehr oder weniger alles gemacht haben, das war ziemlich agil, das war ziemlich agil.
Da gab es deutlich weniger Prozesse, Stonks und alles. Ich will nicht sagen, dass das
sinnlos ist, aber du kannst nicht beides haben. Also es ist nicht möglich beides zu haben.
Du kannst nicht quasi so die 100% Prozessabdeckung und die 100% Anweisung, quasi Vorschriften
anstreben und dann sagen, wir wollen agil sein. Na, das kann ja zusammen nicht funktionieren.
Das funktioniert nur, wenn man dynamisch eben auf neue Sachen reagieren kann und halt
auch den Leuten das zutraut. Sonst funktioniert das nicht. Und beides da irgendwie zusammenzumachen
gibt meiner Meinung nach überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Deathcrab, ich habe jetzt mit denen persönlich noch keinen großartigen Kontakt gehabt, aber
ich glaube, die waren auf der einen Seite relativ überrascht davon, wie viele auf einmal gespielt
haben und also die Venice Leute und ich hatte den Eindruck, es kann sich jetzt aber auch
überhaupt nicht stimmen. Und ich hatte den Eindruck, dass die zwar gerne an dem Mod basteln,
aber sich um die Sachen drum herum, was man so machen muss, dass sowas erfolgreich ist,
nicht so gerne kümmern. Also zum Beispiel eben, dass man auch so eine Art Community-Management
macht. Guckt euch den Twitter-Account an, da wird kaum was gepostet. Der hätte man viel
mehr machen müssen. Die haben zwar einen guten Mod gemacht, aber die Sachen drum herum
waren halt für 2020er-21er-Verhältnisse nicht so berauschend.
Oft ein Battlefield-Fan-Made-Trailer zu reagieren. Zeigt mal her.
Das Problem ist aber auch nicht so sehr die YouTuber an sich. Die auch, klar hätte man
von sich aus sagen können. Bei den großen könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass die bei EA
mal unterschrieben haben, dass man keine moddigen Sachen zeigen darf. Kann durchaus
sein. Aber ich gehe mal davon aus, wenn man da als Venice-Man, als Venice-Community-Manager,
und da hätte es bestimmt Leute gegeben, die sich freiwillig um sowas kümmern haben, andere
Projekte ja auch, mal ein bisschen an die Leute ran getreten wäre, dass man da im Vorfeld
deutlich mehr hätte machen können. Sie haben ja nur geschrieben, wenn ihr Content-Creator
seid, dann meldet euch bei uns. Das klappt meistens nicht. Erstens sind die Leute faul
und je nachdem, wie groß die Channels sind, haben die genug um die Ohren. Du musst schon
aktiv sagen, hier guck mal, wir wissen, du bist großer Battlefield-Fan, du kannst sie
dir auch auf Twitter anschreiben, auf der Business-Adresse. Die waren relativ zurückhaltend.
Das ist halt auch ein bisschen problematisch. Das kannst du in der heutigen Zeit eigentlich
nicht überbringen. Die Leute werden so zugeschissen mit neuen Infos und alles. Du musst das manchmal
schon ein bisschen in your face machen. Echt, ist Battlefield Heroes offline? Das habe ich
doch erst letztens noch gelesen, dass man free to play und Battlefield Heroes wieder
spielen kann. Ja, kann durchaus sein, dass Dice zu machen würde. Aber gut, ich meine,
die Auswahl zwischen Mod-Dead und Mod-Dicht gemacht, dann ist immer noch Mod-Dead der
Schlechtere. Jaja, aber es gibt doch jetzt ein neues Projekt, was das wieder online bringt,
habe ich gelesen. Ja, du kannst ja mal gucken, ob du irgendwelche Krypto-Meiner-Geschichten
findest. Also wenn da ernsthaft solche Sachen drin sind, dann ist es natürlich nicht nur
Todgeburt, sondern dann ist es komplett für immer gestorben. Weil das ist ja kompletter
Vertrauensmissbrauch, aber das kann ich mir ehrlich gesagt nicht vorstellen. Ich bin
aber sowas auch immer recht kritisch, aber das wäre echt schon wir. Jaja, okay, exzellent.
Was gucken wir denn jetzt als erstes Mal? Also, ein Kirby-Musik gucken wir nicht. Ah,
komm mal, es gibt sogar ein Video zu Battlefield 6. Das hat mich heute Morgen ja auch überrascht.
What the fuck? Es ist doch nicht mal die aktuelle Ryzen-Generation draußen, die du dir kaufen
kannst. Wollen die jetzt noch die nächste bringen? Die bringen die nächste, wenn die
alte halbwegs lieferbar ist. Alter, was habe ich denn heute im Hals? Yep, cock. So,
Far Cry, was haben wir denn? FBI warnt vor TeamViewer, okay. Warum das denn? Warum, das
müssen wir uns heute mal angucken. Warum warnt das FBI vor TeamViewer? Moment, Moment. Warum?
Ach, das war die Wasserversorgung. Jaja, das kenne ich, das kenne ich. Die Wasserkraftwerke
und dieses Wasserversorgungsunternehmen, was auf allen Rechnern Windows 7, TeamViewer
und das Standard-Passport drauf hat. Das habe ich gelesen, ja.
... mit der man auf den Desktop von entfernten Rechnern zugreifen kann. Zum Beispiel aus dem Internet. Jetzt werden wahrscheinlich einige sagen, okay, aber das ist nicht neu. Aber die Tatsache, dass das immer noch betont werden muss,
die zeigt dann halt doch, dass das immer noch alle Welt macht. Insoweit jetzt hier einfach direkt die Chance ergriffen und gezeigt, wie man es richtig macht.
Schauen wir uns also deswegen zuerst an, was denn geschehen ist. Das hier ist eine Wasserwiederaufbereitungsanlage in Florida, die das Wasser wiederaufbereitet.
Ja, Freddy, es ist eine Sache, ob das proprietär ist und irgendwie unsicher. Und es ist eine andere Sache, ob man das Tor auch noch aufstehen lässt.
...aufbereiten soll. Ja, das sind Fakten, die lernen wir nur hier. So, und diese Maschine, die wird von einem Computer gesteuert. Und das ist unser Computer.
Wer hätte das gedacht? Windows Vista, Windows Vista hätte man gebrochen.
Der Rechner, der kann auch noch ins Internet gehen. Und zwar über die Leitung, über den Router, direkt ins Netz. Das ist dann der zweite Fehler. Und da hätten wir das Internet.
Der Router. Der Router.
Der Router. Im Nat. Ja. Was ist immer noch zu leise, wirklich?
Kegweight. Ja, bei mir ist das übelst laut.
Jetzt aber, oder?
Weil wir könnten das eigentlich anders machen. Ich mach mal kurz hier rüber auf 100%. Ich mach einfach hier mal lauter.
Die Hintertüren, die am Ende vor der Auslieferung der Software auch immer rausgenommen werden.
Ja gut, das ist ja nichts Neues.
Ja, das hab ich gelesen. Das ist aber sicherlich illegal, oder?
Also es ist bestimmt das eine, wenn die Wasserkraftwerke das offen stehen lassen, aber das auszunutzen für irgendwas ist sicherlich illegal.
Grundsätzlich würd ich wahrscheinlich zu dem Entschluss kommen, dass so ne Maschine überhaupt nicht ans Internet gehört.
Ja, das frag ich mich eh. Warum hängen so Dinger publik im Internet? Aber das frag ich mich bei vielen Kameras und sowas auch. Warum sind die publik im Internet?
Wenn der Windows 7 Rechner die Maschine steuert, ja dann dürfte die Maschine hier einfach nicht mehr ins Internet. Das heißt da müsste ein Schnitt hin. Da muss immer noch ein Mensch dran für solch wichtige Maschinen.
Also wenn Sie daheim die Grunde nur ihre Rolladen runterlaufen lassen wollen oder eben die Heizung umstellen, Fernseher anmachen oder was auch immer, die machen das natürlich genau so nicht, sondern die haben einfach einen VPN-Server.
Ja, VPN oder wisst ihr was noch besser ist? Einfach das ganze nicht Remote zu machen. Weil die meisten Sachen daheim muss man Remote überhaupt nicht steuern.
Genau muss ich Remote den Fernseher anmachen können. Viel besser ist eh bei der Heimautomatisierung, wenn man das Wort Automatisierung auch ernst nimmt und halt die Sachen so weit wie es geht intelligent automatisch machen lässt.
Den kriegt man für wenig Geld im schlimmsten Fall oder im besten Fall. Man kann den Raspberry Pi dafür nehmen. Haben wir alles schon gezeigt. Und dann wird vom Router aus eine Verbindung zum Raspberry Pi gelegt.
Raspberry Pi.
Wenn man sich dann da angemeldet hat, kann dann auf die Rechner zugreifen oder eben direkt die Rolladen steuern. Und wer jetzt fragt, ok, aber ich kann ja auch beim Raspberry Pi ein schwaches Passwort benutzen.
Nein, Raspberry Pi wird überhaupt kein Passwort benutzt, sondern die zum Beispiel OpenVPN Software, die benutzt das Passwort. Und wie wir das entsprechend schon gezeigt haben, das Ganze geschieht überhaupt nicht mehr über ein Passwort, sondern über eine Datei.
Die dann eben zum Beispiel auf ihrem Handy liegt und die Datei kann bis zu 4000 Zeichen lang sein. Das heißt, das Passwort hätte 4000.
OpenVPN in 2021. OpenVPN ist gar nicht übel. Was mir in OpenVPN, was mich da persönlich ein bisschen nervt, ist, dass die Konfig teilweise ein bisschen wir ist und das Setup an sich auch recht aufwendig ist.
Also da finde ich WireGuard wirklich sehr praktisch. Ich weiß gar nicht, hat WireGuard eigentlich mittlerweile den Linux Kernel geschafft?
Das war ja mal vor einer Weile. Aufnahme, Diskussion. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das mittlerweile drin ist.
Es gibt aber auch für IPsec noch Anwendungsgebiete und eines der Aushänge-Dinger von IPsec ist, dass es auf jedem Gerät standardmäßig funst und dabei ist.
Ich mein, iPhones ist das einzige, was die standardmäßig können, glaub IPsec.
Das ist sicher. Jetzt wird der aufmerksame Zuschauer natürlich sagen, Moment mal, hast du nicht gerade was von Hintertür erwähnt?
Also OpenVPN hat eine Hintertür. Nein, OpenVPN ist Open Source. Das heißt, jeder kann dort in den Quellcode schauen und nach Hintertüren suchen.
Könntest du mal im Stream zeigen, wie man WireGuard installiert? Haben wir schon, haben wir schon mal gemacht.
Muss man im Archiv gucken, haben wir schon. Frag mich aber nicht mehr wann.
Also hier kann man schauen. Bei nicht Open Source Software wie dem TeamViewer, da kann man nur vertrauen, aber man kann nicht schauen.
Na ja, und das mit dem vertrauen, das funktioniert echt.
Hä?
Natürlich kann man als Fazit ziehen, die, die das Setup hier eingebaut haben. Das sind natürlich echte Pfeifen gewesen.
Also ich sag mal, der Mitarbeiter oder zumindest die Abteilung, äh, die gehören natürlich...
Hate Speech! Strike ist raus.
Windows 7 bringt schon ein Remote Desktop-Protokoll mit. Das hätte also auch relativ easy benutzt werden können.
Da muss man nicht noch TeamViewer drauf machen.
Ja gut, aber mit Passwort 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 hätte es das glaub auch nicht gebracht.
Das zeigt natürlich, dass die das einfach nur einfach haben wollten.
Ja, und keine Ahnung hatten, was sie machen.
Das fängt natürlich dann da nicht an von wegen, ja aber jetzt geb ich mal ein tolles Passwort von wegen 1 bis 7.
Ja, um die ganze Fraktion von wegen 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 rauszuwerfen.
Also das war natürlich schon ein ganz großer Fehler.
Dass das aber kein Einzelfall ist, das zeigt natürlich unsere Suchmaschine des Vertrauens in Bezug auf, ja, Lücken.
Na ja gut, also ich hab ja prinzipiell bei kaum Sachen Vertrauen, dass sie richtig eingerichtet sind.
Weil ich trau da eigentlich kaum einem was, außer ich hab's schon wiederholt verwendet und es funktioniert halt.
Giant Master hat gefragt, findest du es kritisch einen Port im Router freizuschalten für einen VPN auf dem Pi?
Nö, überhaupt nicht.
Das musst du ja sogar machen, anders geht's ja gar nicht.
Das ist vollkommen okay.
Also wenn du es richtig pro machen willst, dann hast du eine DMZ, in der dein VPN-Server steht.
Weiß ich nicht, ob das mit der Fritzbox geht.
Und man sollte sich nicht irritieren lassen, was normale Router von Multifunktionsgeräte als DMZ verstehen hat mit DMZ eigentlich gar nichts zu tun.
Aber die beste Variante ist, man stellt das in den DMZ, erlaubt den Zugriff darauf.
Und dann macht man eine extra Firewall-Regel, dass man erst nach Authentifizierung quasi vom VPN-Netz dort raus darf in die andere Netze.
Und das ist dann relativ sicher, solange dein VPN ordentlich eingerichtet ist, ja.
Hab ich jetzt hier mal direkt aufgerufen und nach industriellen Kontrollsystemen geschaut und da findet man fast 100.000 Maschinen direkt aus dem Internet.
Ja gut, das Ding ist ja mittlerweile schon recht bekannt.
Das ist das auch was, wo ich mich immer frage, so warum sind so viele Geräte im Internet?
Ich mein, what the f...
Warum brauchen die Leute ihren Kaffeekocher im Internet?
Oder hier direkt nach den Produkten habe ich hier mal aufgerufen.
Da findet man einige und deswegen hier zum Beispiel bei Siemens.
Also nicht von Siemens, aber eben den Port oder die Maschine hat man gefunden.
Realität.
Wenn ich mir das Internet anschaue, was ist das genau?
Dann findet man, dass das dann wieder ein Kontrollrechner ist, der andere Siemens-Maschinen kontrolliert.
Ist halt echt der Witz, ne?
Also wer solche Dinge ins Internet stellt, das ist schon...
Also ich bin der Meinung, es müsste Strafen geben für den, der es ausnutzt, sodass es gefährlich ist für Leute.
Also ich bin nicht da...
Also es gibt ja auch Leute, die sagen so nach dem Motto, hey...
So nach dem Motto, derjenige, der das ausnutzt, dem sollte gar nichts passieren.
Aber ganz ehrlich, ich finde schon, wenn jemand ernsthaft jetzt da hingeht und sagen wir mal so,
die Wasserversorgung so einstellt, dass es Leute vergiftet, natürlich sollte dem was passieren.
Das sollte nicht legal sein, nur weil irgendwelche Leute das Tor aufgelassen haben.
Das pure Einloggen und nichts machen und dem Hersteller Bescheid sagen und sowas, das sollte natürlich nicht bestraft werden.
Aber ich finde, es sollte bei sowas beide abkriegen.
Also sprich, der, der das ausnutzt und Leute gefährdet und natürlich auch die, die das total fahrlässig offen haben stehen lassen.
Natürlich nicht ganz genau, was da kontrolliert wird, aber ich bin mir ganz sicher,
das sollte nicht vom Internet aus so aufrufbar sein.
Ganz bestimmt nicht.
Auch da gehört ein VPN-Server dazwischen, dass man eben nicht genau das sehen kann.
Oder zumindest, oder wenn man das schon, wenn man das wirklich ins Internet stellen will,
was ja meistens schon fragwürdig ist, ob man das überhaupt will.
Wenn man das direkt aus dem Internet, aus dem Browser erreichbar,
dann zumindest ein Reverseproxy davor mit ordentlicher Authentifizierung.
Ja, das lohnt sich. Da werden wir noch mal schauen, ob wir da reinkommen.
Man muss immer zuerst nur den VPN-Server sehen.
Da sehen alle gleich aus und da gibt sich auch keiner Mühe, weil keiner weiß, was dahinter steckt.
Also für alle da draußen, die ohne Wasserwiederaufbereitungsanlage und ohne Siemens-Maschinen im Trautenheim unterwegs sind.
Es gibt 100 gute Gründe, warum man zum Beispiel mit dem eigenen Handy oder mit dem Laptop unterwegs auf die Daten zu Hause zugreifen muss oder möchte.
Das stimmt, aber ich glaube, die meisten brauchen es nicht.
Machen Sie es richtig. Mit einem ordentlichen VPN-Server kostet fast nichts.
Da hat er recht. Da ist sogar einer in Ihrem Router drin.
Da hat er recht. Da gebe ich ihm auch vollkommen recht.
Aber das erste, was man sich überlegen sollte, ist, braucht man überhaupt Zugriff von außen?
Weil ich glaube, viele Leute sagen einfach nur, ja, easy, lass mal anschalten.
So nach dem Motto, ja, wenn wir denn mal irgendwann im Urlaub sind,
dann können wir auch die Rollläden hoch und runter fahren und dann fahren sie in den Urlaub und fahren die Rollläden hoch und runter.
Also man sollte sich wirklich mal überlegen, braucht man das?
Wenn ja, dann per VPN. Aber 99% der Leute brauchen das gar nicht.
Und viel besser ist, als die Rollläden von Hand hoch und runter zu fahren aus dem Urlaub,
ist einfach Automatisierung einzubauen, die das vielleicht mit ein bisschen random Intervall zwischen 17 und 19 Uhr runterfährt oder so.
Oder nach Sonnenuntergang in einem random Intervall von einer Stunde runterfährt und wieder hochfährt und sowas.
Kann man ja machen, ist viel besser. Und man muss auch sonst dann nichts mehr machen.
So, weil jemand gefragt hat nach dem Stream, hier gibt es ein Archiv.
Hier gibt es ein Archiv und eine TXT mit allen Streamtiteln und da steht bestimmt auch irgendwie WireGuard, warum nicht?
Und KS. Wir haben definitiv in WireGuard schon gemacht, aber vielleicht habe ich den Titel vom Stream nicht richtig gewählt.
Archivchamp, ja.
Äh, ja.
Hm, das weiß ich auch nicht.
Archiv, Leute, haben wir den Mod am Start? Das Archivkommando stimmt nicht.
Das muss, ähm, das muss Woplus.tv Archiv sein.
Das ist, hier, da muss das hingehen.
Äh, ja, ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht, wo wir das VPN mal aufgebaut haben.
Ich weiß auch nicht nach, was ich suchen muss. Ich weiß nur, es ist schon ein bisschen her.
Und das Problem ist, ich habe teilweise unglaublich sinnlose, unglaublich sinnloses Streamtitel, wo man auch anhand des Streamtitels nicht so genau erkennt, was da Sache ist.
Was ist denn das hier?
Warte.
Was denn?
Ach, das sind Clips. Warum sind Clips im Archiv drin?
Ja, also Leute, ich habe keine Ahnung, wann wir das mit VPN gemacht haben. Ich weiß nur, dass wir das irgendwann mit WireGuard VPN gemacht haben. Ich habe keine Ahnung mehr, in welchem Stream das war.
Keine Ahnung. Ich guck mal, ich guck mal, ob ich meine eigenen, man kann doch irgendwie seine eigenen Clips durchsuchen.
Inhalte, Clips, äh Clips, Clips meines Kanals, Kategorie. Oh fuck, man kann nicht suchen?
Weil das Ding hat keine Volltextsuche. Okay, RIP.
Pech.
Okay, keine Chance, findste nicht.
Findste, findste nie wieder.
So.
Jetzt gucken wir uns als nächstes an.
Ja, davon habe ich ein paar hier am Start. Was willst du denn wissen?
Die sind nicht schlecht, die Dinger.
Die sind nicht schlecht, die Dinger sind vor allem günstig. Also es geht um so einen Controller.
Die sind vor allem ziemlich günstig. Ja gut, jetzt vielleicht nicht bei Amaz. Das sind aber auch die falschen, das sind die richtigen.
Eigentlich viel zu teuer hier gerade, aber das liegt wahrscheinlich daran, weil die Chinesen nichts produzieren.
Die Chinesen? Der 5V Pin ist ein Input, oder? Nee, beides. Beides. Du kannst den powern.
Du kannst den powern und du kannst darüber glaube ich auch 5V abkabeln. Also wenn du, wenn du, warte mal.
Ich glaube das ist beides.
Pin.
Genau, also ich bin mir da relativ sicher, du kannst den powern über den 5V pinnen.
Oder wenn du es über USB angeschlossen hast, kannst du da 5V von absapfen.
Also geht beides.
Und äh, ja.
Ja. Der verkraftet übrigens auch ein bisschen mehr als 5V, aber ich würde es nicht übertreiben.
Wird heiß.
Ja, exzellent, exzellent. Genau, so.
Guck mal, ich krieg mein eigenes Video empfohlen, da klicken wir jetzt drauf und klicken auf Ende vom Video mal.
Wobei das zählt nicht als geschaut, aber ähm, ich muss jetzt ein bisschen durchklicken, weil ganz wichtig, also
ich muss ja meine Viewzeit erhöhen. Kann nicht sein, dass ich ein Video empfohlen krieg und nicht anklick.
Das macht ja meine Clickthrough Rate total kaputt.
So, jetzt hab ich genug geguckt.
Greetings.
Ja gut, HalfLife 1 hatte schon so ein paar merkwürdige Dinger.
So, was schauen wir uns jetzt an? Zeig ich mal hier, eine Runde Battle.
Ich hoffe, er hat nicht zu viel... Moment, das ist...
Okay, es sind kaum Flugzeugclips, weil Flugzeugclips sind immer langweilig, wenn man sich 5 Minuten Flugzeugclips anguckt.
Welchen VPN-Anbieter würdest du empfehlen? Gar keinen, ich würde das selbst machen.
Es sei denn, du möchtest diesen, nennen wir es mal Anonymisierungsaspekt verwenden, dann ist es wahrscheinlich fast egal.
Zudu ist ein bloated mess. Ich glaub, das Video kenn ich. Der Typ ist aber, für den Typ ist aber alles bloated.
Für den ist auch Wim bloated.
Okay, komm. Leute, wisst ihr was? Mir ist jetzt der Null, wir gucken jetzt eine Runde Black Ops 1.
Weiß auch nicht warum. Wo ist jetzt die Runde?
What is going on, guys? What's going on?
What's going on?
Black Ops 1 Video, it's been quite a bit since I've last played Black Ops 1.
But I had this idea today as I was scrolling through the guns, looking maybe what can I do?
And I had this idea about the Spectre. I'm not even sure if I'm saying that right, but this was a gun I...
Spectre. Ich hab immer gesagt Spectre, Spectre, Spectre.
...used back in the day, maybe a few times playing search and destroy, and then completely forgot this gun.
The meaning behind it is that the VPN-Anbieter make money.
I feel like Black Ops 1 had a ton of submachine guns that were just...
Die Lautstärke, okay.
...kind of overlooked.
Ich hab jetzt extra ein bisschen lauter gemacht, insgesamt.
The AK-74U and the MP5 were honestly the main two submachine...
Beste, beste AK-74U Griff rapid fire in your face.
...guns here, even the MPL, the PM63, a lot of these guns normally...
Oder, oder Silencer rapid fire for free for all, war auch okay.
...used because obviously there was the AK-74U and the MP5.
Ja, ja, okay, blabla.
So now you can't hear anything.
It's all good though, maybe it's a sign I can get some better gaming.
Ey, was war denn das Ding nochmal? War das das Respawn-Beacon, oder war das der Motion-Sensor?
Oder was war denn das nochmal, dieses komische Ding da?
Right here.
Oh, viel zu laut, Alter.
So, we're using the Spectre, we've got these silencer extended mags here.
Jetzt mach ich ein bisschen leiser, weil ich laber eh drüber.
Just having some fun on Black Ops 1.
Die Spectre, die Spectre.
Okay, man sieht jetzt daran, das war halt Hit-Detection-mäßig und Latency-mäßig war es halt auch shit.
Aber das war halt auch komplett P2P, mehr oder weniger.
Und man es jetzt P2P ernennt, oder anders.
Zumindest ist das gelaufen auf der Xbox von irgendeinem Typ, der im Match teilgenommen hat.
Und das war auch nicht alles rosig, ja.
Den gibt's immer noch.
Ja, ja, EC-ABS, den gibt's immer noch.
Der regt sich immer noch über jedes Call of Duty auf.
Ja, beste, beste.
URV Blackbird Hunde, beste Killstreak.
Das war halt auch typisch, damals die ganzen P2P Lobbies.
Die Leute hatten so einen heftigen Lack, die sind noch in dich reingelaufen, während du schon stehen geblieben bist und geschossen hast.
Das hatte nichts damit zu tun, dass man irgendwie so eine ultra krassere Reaction-Time als die Gegner hat.
Sondern die Verbindung war einfach kacke.
Lacked.
Spectre hat ja auch gesagt.
Das war so ein typisches Phänomen von Call of Duty auf der Konsole, dieser Typ.
Das hab ich so auf dem PC noch nie gesehen.
Auf der Konsole kommt das aber in allen Spielen irgendwie vor.
Das Leute...
Pass mal auf.
Das Leute einfach random in der Ecke stehen, so wie der hier, und sich nicht bewegen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das irgendwie so die... die...
Console-Casual-Leute sind.
Die dann einfach während der Runde sagen, ich geh mal kurz AFK aufs Klo, ist ja nicht so schlimm, wenn ich gekillt werde.
Oder wie das ist.
Aber das hab ich bisher nur auf der Konsole gehabt.
Leute, die einfach random in einem Multiplayer-Match rumstehen und offensichtlich AFK sind.
Die versuchen zu zielen.
Nee, der Typ war AFK.
Pharma ist das Beste.
Achso, geht nur SMGs.
Ja, AK-74, Rapid, Fire und Sire Lancer oder Griff, Fire auch das Beste.
Ja, Deathgrabbes hätte mich auch echt gewundert, weil die hätten sich ja instant komplett jegliches Vertrauen verspielt, was total hängen geblieben wäre, wenn man da irgendwie acht Jahre dran arbeitet und es so verkackt.
Man arbeitet ja auch nicht acht Jahre dran, um es dann rauszubringen mit einem Kryptominer.
Aber man weiß nicht, du hast schon recht, nachgucken ist besser als Vertrauen, ja.
Blackbird, bester Killstreak.
Du kannst, wenn du gerade dabei bist, fixen noch mal das Memory-Leak.
Oh, jetzt hab ich die Lautstärke lauter gemacht.
Jetzt ist mein Meme-Board auch lauter.
Oh, Achtung, Achtung.
Haltet euch die Ohren zu.
Viel zu laut. Jetzt muss ich das erst mal ein bisschen leiser machen, Moment mal.
Mixer.
Das hier.
Auf normale Lautstärke machen.
Ich glaub, jetzt normale Lautstärke.
Das hab ich auch immer.
UAV, Blackbird, Hunde.
Oder man konnte auch, wenn es noch mehr Kills sein sollen, Napalmstrike, Blackbird, Hunde, war auch nice.
Oder die Nuke-Town-Chopper-Gunner, Leute.
Ja, die Sacken.
Guckt euch mal die Splitscreen-Tools an.
Bro, Bro.
94.
Man darf nicht vergessen, 94.
Das waren in Black Ops 1, waren das die Kinder, die rumgeschrien haben noch.
Heute sind 94 Leute, auch 26 oder so.
Heute, Leute mit 94 im Game Attack, haben in Black Ops 1 noch rumgeschrien, ich fick deine Mutter.
Und heute sind es die 26.
Murdoc weiß ich nicht mehr.
Wie ihr habt das mit 16 nicht gemacht?
Murdock weiß ich nicht mehr.
Wie, ihr habt das mit 16 nicht gemacht?
Ich hab das mit 26 immer noch gemacht, Leute, geflamed.
Ich flame auch, was heißt flame, ich flame auch heute noch gerne Leute.
Oder ärgere Leute im Chat.
Ich hab nie, ich hab nie flamed voice messages aufgenommen.
Also ich hab nie diese Geschichten gemacht.
Ah, alter du kak Hurensohn, ich fick deine Mutter und dann per, per voice chat geschickt.
Nee, nee, das hab ich nicht gemacht.
Aber ich, ich ähm, ärgere immer noch Leute im Chat ganz gerne.
Was weiß ich, dass die Sachen too easy waren oder sowas.
Die Gegner sind aber, was ist das für ne Lobby?
So, so Lobbies bräuchtest du mal in Cold War oder MW2.
Äh, nicht MW2, MW.
Oh, schreckt.
Einfach reingerannt.
By the way, by the way, wenn ihr euch da noch an Xbox Sprachnachrichten erinnert, wisst ihr was, wisst ihr was echt erschreckend ist?
Dass Nintendo es noch nicht geschafft hat, eine online, eine online, wie sagt man heutzutage so schön, eine online experience rauszubringen.
Die auch nur ansatzweise an eine Konsole von vor 15 Jahren rankommt.
Oh, da liegt er in der Ecke und hat es nicht gecheckt.
Also die haben aber auch zwei linke Hände, ey.
Auf der Wii, na auf der Wii war es ja noch schlimmer.
Da haben die noch mehr mit Freundesliste und Geschiss rumhantiert.
Screw, we'll just throw it over there.
Timebreak the 40 bomb.
Napalm strike with a double kill, let's go.
We broke the 40 bomb, three kills.
Äh, nicht Freundesliste, Freundescodes meine ich ja.
Oh my gosh.
It's an absolute slaughterfest.
Alter, sind das Kacken.
So Lobbies braucht man, Alter.
So Lobbies, so muss das sein.
Oh, voll in die Eier geballert.
Boah, da ist die Moab.
Wisst ihr was die bei Microsoft jetzt bei einer Xbox Gamescore sagt?
Wisst ihr was die auch mit dem Wechsel zur Xbox One total verkackt haben?
Die haben ja quasi ihr komplettes Interface und so auch diese prominente Platzierung von Gamerscore und Xbox Avatar und sowas.
Haben die ja auch komplett zugunsten dieses Einheitskarreldesigns weggeschmissen.
Es war richtig geil, damals gab es total viele die so Gamescore-Hunting gemacht haben.
Wisst ihr, die haben sich auch so richtige Scheißspiele gekauft.
Kennt noch einer dieses Avatar-Game für die Xbox, wo du 5 Minuten für 1100 Gamerscore gebraucht hast?
Xbox, 360, Avatar, GS, Gamer.
Das da.
1000 Gamerscore in 1 Minute.
Genau, du wusstest einfach nur, du wusstest einfach nur in das Game.
Du wusstest einfach nur, du wusstest einfach nur in das Game und am Start Knöpfe drücken.
Du wusstest einfach nur Knöpfe gedrückt halten für eine Minute und hast 1100 Gamerscore gehabt.
Wir haben uns das Spiel, der Fabian hat sich damals das Spiel extra gekauft und wir haben uns, wir haben uns das dann,
ich habe mir das dann ausgeliehen und wieder zurückgeschickt und er hat es noch einem ausgeliehen.
Nur für 1000 Gamerscore.
Guck mal, das ist alles, was du machen musst für 1000 Gamerscore.
Das ist so schlecht.
Huge Graphics auch, by the way.
Du wusstest einfach nur, du wusstest einfach nur spammen für 1000 Gamerscore.
Guck mal, du wusstest nichts machen.
Einfach nur Knopf drücken.
Aber wieso? Guck mal hier.
Naja, weil sich das Game besser verkauft, weil das Game kacke ist. Was bringt der Gamerscore flexen?
Guck mal, so failed.
Ich kann mich da noch dran, wir haben das Game dann geshared mit noch ein paar Leute für mehr Gamerscore.
Guck mal, also so easy Gamerscore gab es noch nirgendwo, wie bei diesem Game.
Na gut, zumindest mit dem Wechsel auf die Xbox One haben sie es halt total verkackt,
weil die Xbox-Avatare wurden quasi versteckt. Weiß gar nicht, ob man die heute noch überhaupt irgendwo sieht.
Und Gamerscore wurde auch langweilig. Ich fand das richtig geil.
Wir haben damals versucht, die Spiele immer mit 1000 Gamerscore plus durchzuspielen und sowas.
Und es war gar nicht schwer. Du musstest sogar Call of Duty 5 Veteran durchspielen.
Und ganz ehrlich, Call of Duty 5 Veteran war echt Cancer. Granaten-Spam ohne Ende.
Wie unsicher wirrens. Hab ich schon gemacht.
Ich hab mich schon öfters mal über Antivirus ausgelassen, dass es schwachsinnig ist.
Früher, ganz, ganz früher, als Windows Defender noch nicht am Start war und am Anfang von Windows Defender,
hab ich gesagt, so ein kostenloser Virenschutz kann ja nix schaden in den Videos.
Aber ich hab gefühlt die letzten acht Jahre, erzähl ich, Antivirus sackt.
Also da hab ich mich schon öfters darüber ausgelassen.
Oh, voll in die Eier geballert.
Ich hab mich auch mal in einem Video darüber ausgelassen, als es diese JavaScript-Lücke im Windows Defender gab.
Vielleicht erinnert sich da noch der eine oder andere dran.
Der Windows Defender hatte mal einen Bug, weil der Windows Defender einen eingebauten JavaScript-Interpreter hatte.
Und man konnte mit einer manipulierten Webseite quasi den Windows Defender kaputt machen.
Und ich bin mir gar nicht mal sicher, ob man nicht sogar irgendwelche Sachen dort dann ausführen konnte.
Es war richtig, richtig für'n Arsch, ja.
Man fragt sich natürlich, warum hat ein Virenscanner einen JavaScript-Interpreter, der mit Hutrechten läuft.
Wobei, es sind ja sogar noch mehr als Hutrechte, was der Windows Defender hat.
So, das sind wieder die Splitscreen-Oops.
Die Maps in Black Ops 1 waren eh nice.
Also, was man halt...
Ich mein, das ist nicht Radiation, das ist Lounge.
Das ist nicht Radiation. Oder? Bin ich jetzt total Pepega?
Das Lounge, das ist das mit der Rakete, wo die Rakete links steht.
Radiation war diese andere Map mit dem, mit dem, mit dem Tor, was man auf und zu machen kann.
Brrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrr
Oh ne, lasst den! Please! Nein!
Ja, es ist Lounge. Hier oben ist die, hier oben ist die Rakete.
Da ist die, ist die Rakete.
Aber man sieht auch schönes, klassisches Drei-Wege-Layout mit dem Unterschied,
dass es hier eigentlich Vier-Wege durch die Rakete sind.
ist die ist die rakete aber man sieht auch schönes klassisches drei wege layout mit dem unterschied dass es hier eigentlich viel wege durch die
Rakete sind also die maps waren schon cool
Ruby
Da sind die split screener wieder der typ der typ hat ihn nicht getroffen weil er rumgesprungen ist war zu pepega pepega
Warum gibt es dem gelben noch so viele nups man erkennt man hat nups immer richtig gut daran erkannt in den alten games dass sie
So rumgelaufen sind wie dieser tut gerade
So guck der typ der typ rennt nicht der typ läuft und ist permanent im ironside ich weiß nicht was mit dem typ abgeht aber
So waren sie halt
Hast du smarte heizungsthermostate ja das problem ist
Da ist heute die batterie leer und jetzt geht es nicht mehr
Das sagt also ich habe mir so ein china thermostat gekauft vor einer weile weil ich die geil fand und ich wollte mir eigentlich noch mehr
Kaufen habe ich glücklicherweise nicht gemacht
Weil
Die doch nicht so gut sind die ich habe das im december eingebaut und jetzt ist die batterie leer also voll für den arsch also ich
Bin der meinung generell bei allen wireless geräten die batterie muss mindestens ein jahr halten sonst ist das komplett useless
Sonst bist ja stell dir mal vor du hast das haus versorgt mit
Löht doch ein netzteil dran ja wo ist denn der sinn davon wenn ich es gibt welche mit kabel aber ich will ja gerade ohne kabel
Welche
äh äh moment moment moment
Wieder also die gibt es von zig verschiedenen herstellern aber es ist alles das gleiche china gerät drunter
Wieder also die sind eigentlich ganz gut und auch günstig verhältnismäßig günstig im vergleich zu den andern
Aber es muss es muss ohne miss es muss ein jahr halten weil stellt ihr mal stellt euch mal vor
Eure ganzen wireless geräte halten halten irgendwie nur drei vier monate dann seid ihr quasi täglich am batterien wechseln
Äh n-ocean ist cool aber n-ocean war doch die sache komplett ohne batterie die quasi beim schalten
Durch die durch die energie des schaltvorgangs des kommando senden können ich wusste gar nicht dass es dazu thermostate gibt
Na gut solar solar
Solar bringt mir jetzt an der stelle für die
Thermostate nix weil da ist ja kein sonn ich könnte es dann oben auf die fensterbank legen oder so
Was gibt es denn da so nach was nach was soll ich nach was soll ich denn so ich bin jetzt nicht mehr auf dem fernseher
Zeig mal was gibt es denn da so nach was nach was soll ich nach was soll ich denn so n-ocean thermostate
Das sind die ghost rider das sind die die sind die sind kompatibel ich habe hier selbst ein konbi 2
So zeigt mal her was gibt es da kurz kurz gedudel anmachen boah alter das sieht ja aus wie 1970
So was wie als hätte meine oma noch eingebaut im keller what the fuck
Alter also dafür kann ich viele sickbip geräte und batterien kaufen für 124 euro
Das ist zu teuer das ist zu teuer
Das ist zu teuer
124 euro von thermostate meine fresse ist das teuer what the fuck
Welche gibt es mit solar
Der anbau ist nicht schwierig nein das anbau ist easy easy schraubst das alte ab schraubst das neue dran
Das sagt doch alles
Dann nehme ich lieber ein kleines ich thermo starten wechsel die batterien wisst ihr was ich noch da habe ich habe noch ein fritz
thermostat am start das wollte ich mal ausprobieren
Habe ich schon ewig rumliegen bei mir so ein teil da
fritz
Die rote pest aus berlin ist jetzt auch an der heizung
Aber zum glück haben sie es nicht rot gemacht ja
also
So ein ding so ein ding habe ich habe ich auch noch ewig rumliegen das wollte ich das wollte ich mal ausprobieren
Ich hoffe da hält der hält das thermostat die batterien
bisschen länger
Aus berlin ja
Captain peng es gibt nur einen gott beeler farin rott weis ihr doch
Aber das ist ja preislich echt absolut jenseits aller aller sachen die man sich kaufen sollte ja
Ne ne ne ne
Okay wir gucken jetzt erstmal fertig
schnapper fantast viruses
richtiger schnapper ja
Zoom in fot literature
rhubrig
aber
Lassen sich aber auch krass weg sp athlete so lobby bräuchte auch mein mw. Und showed war
Alter, die lassen sich aber auch krass wegspringen gerade bei den Gegnern.
So Lobbies bräuchte es da auch mal ein MW und Cold War.
Scheiß auf Skill-Base-Met-
Guck mal, schon wieder so ein Afk-Typ.
Ja, oh, das wird ein guter, das wird ein guter Napalm-Strike, Leute.
Das wird ein guter Napalm-Strike.
Be-
Keg-Wade?
Okay, zwei ist okay.
Ich hab gedacht, es gibt mindestens vier Kills, äh-
Nee, das hab ich nicht gesehen.
All bang him? He's weak? Oh my-
Who jumped down?
Serious Max, was ist denn der lila-Screen?
Oh, is that guy?
Dogs are eating again, holy crap, let's go!
Boah, Alter, die Kills, die-
Die-
Bashen, aber auch, Alter!
Guckt euch mal die Hunde an, die haben bestimmt schon acht Kills gemacht oder so.
I wasn't surviving there, there was just no way. I was looking at the wrong angle and then they both shot me at the same time and then stabbed me.
I was screwed.
Nee, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich kenn kein lila-Screen.
Moment.
Twitch-Purple-Screen.
Was da?
Ach, das Ding!
Doch, doch, doch, das hab ich mal gesehen.
Auf der Seite, wo du mehrere Streams parallel gucken konntest. Ja, doch, doch, den kenn ich.
Daran sieht man mal, wie geil das Ganze ohne Skill-Base-Batchmaking ist.
Es muss ja nicht jede Runde sein, aber das Coole ist, dass du halt auch mal öfter solche Runden hast.
Die Runde danach ist wieder scheiße und du kriegst voll auf den Sack, aber so muss das Arcade-mäßig Call of Duty auch sein.
Wenn du Ranking haben willst, dann spielst du ranked.
Da kannst du wenigstens Schwanzvergleich mit einem Rank machen.
Ne, Spectre kannst du wunderbar ohne Sight spielen.
Nice!
Boah, die werden aber auch gebashed einfach.
Guckste dir an! Guckste dir an!
Die Noobs! Ist ja geil, Alter!
Die Commander-Krieger Wauzis sind am Start.
Kennst du noch Battlefield Heroes? Ja, kenn ich noch.
One more kill, one more kill, one more kill.
Nooo, I didn't get it. 39 and 3.
Damn, that was a pretty sick gameplay though for joining in real late.
We raise the Reflex Sight, we're gonna switch up some kills for you guys.
Hopefully, you guys haven't seen them in a while, just to refresh your memory.
We're gonna use the Reflex Sight, we've got a couple more kills for you guys.
We're gonna use the Reflex Sight, we've got a custom reticle, custom lens, blue and blue.
Reflex Sight silencer, let's freakin' roll out here, boys.
We've got some new killstreaks as well. Klar gibt's den noch, der ist jetzt auf Twitch am Start.
Take the free double kill, one of my new killstreaks.
I forget what I put on, I put on mortar t-
No, did I put on mortar? Die Predator-Schnubbelmaschine, genau!
Oh, Paints-Champ.
Oh, I've got Rolling Thunder, Valkyrie Rockets and Gunship.
Let's see if we can get those, let's go, baby.
We're off to a good start, 4-0. Anyone up here? No.
Aber, insofern, die Sache hat er schon richtig gemacht.
Den Kram kennt heute immer noch fast jeder.
Auch wenn es Paints-Champ war.
Was ist mit dem Typ los?
Was ist mit dem Gegner los?
Schon wieder der Typ!
Ja, Arrow die erzählen viel, wenn der Tag lang ist.
Also, eine Sache gab es in allen Call of Duty.
Es gab das normale Matchmaking und es gab das ultra-low Matchmaking.
Das gab es aber schon immer.
Und das haben die, glaube ich, gemacht für Leute, die ja mit Behinderungen gespielt haben und sowas.
Die nicht richtig sehen konnten, was die Controller richtig bedienen konnten.
Also, es gab schon immer so ein ultra-low Matchmaking und das normale.
Also, wenn die das und das skill-based Matchmaking verkaufen wollen, dann gab es das schon immer.
Aber das hat ja nichts mit dem skill-based Matchmaking zu tun, was durch alle Skill-Ranks sich durchzieht.
Und dich matcht gegen ähnlich gute, wie es seit mehr oder weniger angefangen mit Black Ops 2.
Aber richtig krass, dass es seit MW2 am Start ist.
Aber so diese ultra-noob-low-lobby, die hatten sie schon immer.
Aber das ist ganz normales Matchmaking.
By the way, stellt euch mal vor, Battlefield 6 kommt raus und ist ein ultrageiles Game.
Und dann hat skill-based Matchmaking.
Und komplett Serverbrowser rausgeworfen, Customserver rausgeworfen.
Du kannst bloß noch über Matchmaking joinen.
Stellt euch das mal vor.
Messer, Messer, Messer, Messer, Messer, Messer, Messer, Messer, Messer, Messer.
Na?
Dolphindive.
Wie hieß der Typ noch mal?
Wie hieß der Typ damals zu Black Ops...
Ihr wisst wenig mein.
Der immer diese dämlichen Dolphindive-Videos gemacht hat.
wo er irgendwo reingesprungen ist, wo ich mich damals schon gefragt habe, wer guckt sich diesen...
Whiteboy7street, Whiteboy7street, jetzt weiß ich es wieder, jetzt weiß ich es wieder, ja, ja, ja, genau.
Ich fand das damals schon total unlustig, aber das war mega gehypt.
Gibt's den überhaupt noch heute?
Whiteboy7street, gibt's den heute noch?
Was? Musical Artist, Music Artist ist er heute.
Was macht der denn für Musik?
Okay.
So wirklich gucken tut es auch keiner mehr, oder?
Nee.
Ist auch... gut, so ist das halt teilweise auf YouTube, wenn du so, so Dinger machst, die halt nur
in dieser einen, in dieser einen Game-Generation gehen,
dann ist halt vorbei, ja.
Was ist eigentlich mit Bad Company 3?
Ja, das wurde damals ja auch geleakt, dass die angeblich dran arbeiten, aber danach kam wohl die
Meldung, das wird nicht weiterverfolgt.
Ich gehe davon aus, da war was dran.
Der Typ hat ja damals auch schon Battlefield 1 und Battlefield 5 relativ detailliert genau geleakt.
Also ich gehe davon aus, da war was dran, aber die haben es wahrscheinlich nicht weiterverfolgt dann.
Check.
Leute, please bewegt euch doch mal, sitzt doch nicht einfach rum.
Okay, ich wüsste gar nicht mehr, wie man das steuert.
Hatte das auch schon Raketen in Black Cops 1?
Ich glaube schon.
Und ich sehe zum ersten Mal jetzt, dass Firing Range davor noch eine komische Helibase hat.
So ein Trainingskurs, das habe ich noch nie gesehen.
Ah, erstmal schon Raketen reinbashing.
Das geile an Firing Range war, du konntest glaube ich so ziemlich durch alle Gebäude durchschießen.
Hau Raketen da rein in das Ding, jawoll.
Bashing, alter Bashing.
Wie, der ist nicht gestorben an den Raketen?
Ich, ich mochte, ich mochte Hunde deutlich mehr als einfach weil man was machen konnte.
Green Style, danke schön für den Prime Sub.
Dieser Killstreak, der war eigentlich richtig geil, aber der war zu hoch.
Deswegen hat den kaum einer genommen, der war eigentlich richtig geil.
Und man hat sich easy selbst damit gekillt.
So eine kacke Killstreak.
Was?
Warum stehen die einfach da und gucken grad aus?
Der zeigt das.
Mobile auf dem PC mit Emulator spielst du gegen Bots?
Die so aussehen als wären es echte Gegner.
Das Game erkennt das ob du Emulator oder gegen echte Gegner spielst.
Ob du Emulator oder Mobile spielst.
Der packt Emulator Spieler zusammen ins Matchmaking und füllt mit Bots auf.
Das heißt du hast zu 90% gegen Bots gespielt.
Nee, pass auf gleich stirbt der.
Ich wusste, immer wenn du sagst das Game ohne sterben bist du weg.
Wo kommt der her?
Wo ist der da gespawnt?
Der ist gespawnt oder?
Er ist nicht da, er ist nicht da.
Der ist gespawnt hier grad neben dem.
Woher weißt du das mit dem Emulator und den Bots?
Das ging damals durch Reddit News und sonst was.
Es gibt Leute die haben das ausprobiert, die trennen das.
Es wäre ja auch ziemlich bescheuert wenn du Leute mit Maus und Tastatur, PC ins Matchmaking mit den Mobile Spielern werfen würdest.
Was natürlich funktionieren würde ist, wenn du einen Android Emulator verwendest und das Spiel darauf quasi als Mobile spielst, falls das irgendwie geht.
Wenn du das mit dem offiziellen Emulator machst, dann kommen die Leute ins eigenes Matchmaking.
Das waren ein paar echt geile Runden.
Tastatur und Maus am Tablet.
Ich weiß nicht ob das das Game unterstützt.
Die Splitscreen Dudes.
Schreckt.
Get schreckt.
Übrigens, ich muss euch mal was zum Thema Pepofet erzählen.
Ich hab mir ein Probierpaket bestellt.
Von der Seite mit der schlechtesten Website aller Zeiten.
Guckt euch mal diesen Onlineshop an.
Wer auch immer diesen Onlineshop gemacht hat, der sollte seine Webdesign Kenntnisse nochmal etwas überdenken.
Ich hab sogar ein Webcam.
Das ist ein Weingut in Italien, wo man sich Essen bestellen kann.
So und da hab ich mir ein Probierpaket bestellt.
Probierpaket Pasta und Soßen.
Wohlgemerkt 37 Euro mit Versand 40 Euro.
Eigentlich viel zu teuer.
Schmeckt aber echt übertrieben geil.
Moment Details was da drinnen.
Ah diese Webseite.
Nein das ist das falsche.
Ok ok ich will wissen was drin ist.
Moment man konnte sich doch irgendwie jetzt.
Leute ich bin unfähig diese Seite zu bedienen, man konnte sich doch anzeigen lassen was drin ist.
Was ist das für ne Webseite alter.
Ok wie kann man sich anzeigen lassen was da drin ist.
Ah ok.
Alles klar wer hätte da.
Wow nein.
Ok man darf da nicht drauf drücken sonst ist RIP wenn man da drauf drückt.
Zumindest was man bekommt ist 500g Spaghetti, 500g Fuseli, 500g Regatoni und nochmal andere Fuseli und viel Soßen.
Das ist natürlich im Vergleich zu Lidl Preisen echt heftig.
Aber ich hab am Freitag oder so hab ich das hier gegessen.
Das da Fuseli aus stein gemahlenem Dinkel Vollkornmehl.
Klingt jetzt erst mal ultra öko.
Aber hat in Kombination mit.
Ich glaub das da hab ich gefuttert.
Das in Kombination hat richtig geil geschmeckt.
Da muss man nicht viel kochen man macht einfach die Nudel warm und gießt dann das Zeug drüber.
Also da muss man nicht wirklich kochen.
Also du kochst die Nudel und schmeißt dann die Soße drüber.
Richtig geil also kann man echt empfehlen schmeckt wirklich gut.
Es ist halt ein bisschen teuer wenn man sich überlegt.
Man bekommt 4 Packen Nudeln und 4 Packen Soße für 40 Euro.
Was halt 5 Euro pro Teil sind.
Also das kriegst du beim Lidl kriegst du die Kombination für keine Ahnung 9 Euro.
Aber dafür schmeckt es halt gut.
Die haben übrigens noch mehr.
Bei denen kannst du auch probier Pakete.
Perlen was gibt es denn Perlen zwischen Wein oder sowas was brauch ich denn.
Wein alter Lulwe.
Die haben doch irgendwie das da das da.
Guck mal.
Peppofett.
Kriegste.
Kriegste Wurst.
Käse.
Soßen.
Nudeln.
Noch mehr Soße.
Öl.
Süßkram.
Ja und Weinzeug wenn man drauf steht.
Talkwalk.
Danke für den Zap.
Das Problem bei mir ist ich bin nicht der großartige Weintrinker aber vielleicht schmeckt es ja von denen auch nicht schlecht.
Man muss halt mal sagen.
In dem Fall halt echt krass.
130 Euro für Futter.
Schon ordentlich.
Beschreibung oben in der Mitte.
Hier gibt es keine Beschreibung oben in der Mitte.
Hier gibt es keine Beschreibung.
Ach jetzt muss man drauf klicken.
Seit 2012 exzellent.
Guck mal hier ist aber ziemlich ziemlich viel dabei ja.
Also ist auf jeden Fall ist auf jeden Fall nice was die haben das jetzt nicht unbedingt das ist halt viel zu übertrieben.
Viel zu viel zu übertrieben aber sehr nice.
Exzellent.
Ok also schauen wir uns jetzt an.
Ok also was was sagt uns die GameStar was denn 2021 geiles gibt?
Zeig her.
Mal gucken mal gucken wer der Sprecher ist.
Ach das ist der das ist der der immer das das es so super super essig ausspricht.
Uns.
Oh nein das kann ich mir jetzt nicht geben das ist mir zu anstrengend.
Also was was gibt es denn?
Shadow Warrior 3.
Ne doch das müssen wir mal gucken.
Shadow Warrior 3 wird denke ich.
Also ich persönlich mir hat Shadow Warrior 1 gut also die Remakes haben mir gut gefallen.
Und Shadow Warrior 2 fand ich auch geil.
Und das 3 wird bestimmt auch nice.
Also reden wir gar nicht länger um den heißen Brei herum.
Hier sind die spannendsten Ego Shooter die noch 2021 erschienen.
Ok das neue Halo wird glaube ich auch wieder so ein Ding wo glaube ich viele Leute enttäuscht von werden.
Scheinen sollen.
Irgendwie muss ich auch ehrlich sagen habe ich den Eindruck die Luft aus Halo ist auch raus.
Das war ja mal auf einem Level mit so Call of Duty und sonst was von der Beliebtheit her.
Vielleicht nicht ganz so hoch aber gerade auf der Xbox mittlerweile geht nach Halo echt kein Haar mehr.
Es gab ja auch mal eine relativ aktive E-Sport Szene und alles aber das ist komplett komplett dead.
Los geht's mit einem richtigen Kracher im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes.
Ja da bin ich mal gespannt drauf.
Und schnetzelt sich mit seinem Katana in Shadow Warrior 3 wieder durch Dutzende Dämonen.
Und keine Sorge Schusswaffen sind auch wieder mit an Bord.
Wie sollen wir es denn sonst mit diesem Dickerchen hier aufnehmen.
Teil 3 richtet sich außerdem wieder mehr an Fans des ersten Serienteils.
Loot und Zufalls generierte Level sind Geschichte.
Stattdessen warten handgebaute Areale und einige neue Gameplay Mechaniken auf uns.
Per Greifhaken schwingt sich Lo herum, per Wallrunning nutzen wir die Umgebung besser aus.
Shadow Warrior 3 soll zudem genauso albern wie die Vorgänger werden.
Wie sich die neuen Fertigkeiten schlagen sollen wir noch dieses Jahr auf PC und Konsole feststellen.
Welche Konsole genau das ist noch nicht bekannt.
Wir gehen aber zumindest fest von einer PS5 und Xbox Series X Fassung aus.
Das wird für beides erscheinen denke ich mal.
Weil aktuell ist es ja so es gibt ja kaum was auf den neuen Konsolen.
Viele Leute haben noch die alten. Das ist gerade so wieder die Übergangszeit wo was für alt und neu erscheint.
Na bin ich ja mal gespannt ob das neue Halo genial wird.
Es wäre auf jeden Fall nice wenn mal ein gescheites Halo kommt.
Graven will den Geist von klassischen Shootern wie etwa der Hexenreihe wieder aufleben.
Grafik inspiriert aus den 90ern.
Waffen, Zauber und Rätsel könnten den Shooter durchaus zu einem echten Geheimtipp machen.
Sieht aus als hat einer den Quake 2 Engine Level Editor rausgeholt.
Sieht auch aus als hat einer den Quake 2 Engine Level Editor rausgeholt.
warum ist in diesen ganzen games warum haben da die nazis im zweiten weltkrieg
immer irgendwelche komischen robot am start die war nicht mal in der nähe so
was zu bauen in einem video zusammengefasst das haben die total
gerne in solchen alternativ realitätsspielen warum haben die
irgendwelche robot immer am start erscheint 2021 erst einmal nur für den
ach Moment Moment kalter krieg ok ich habe was von zweiten weltkrieg
verstanden ihr habt recht aber trotzdem da hat auch keiner da hat auch keiner
robot am start gehabt
haben wir mehr krach machen blies
mit farkr6 kehren wir das erste mal seit teil 3 auf eine karibische insel
zurück als geriat das ist da das ist da wo die leute vermutet haben der junge
wäre war es wie er klein war aber ich ich ich koale ja schwachsinn aber das
regime des diktators ergibt auch keinen sinn aber man weiß ja nie das tio und
werden dafür wieder dutzende von gegnern niedermäher kockweiler hat hier
irgendwie über einem auge hat er mit dem auge hat er irgendwie eine nabe und was
hat angeblich auch eine nabe und deswegen haben die leute schon wieder
teorie craft das wäre was wieder klein war ganz davon abgesehen er sieht ihm
nicht mal wirklich ähnlich und was ist ja eigentlich in afrika auf dieser
insel geboren aber egal wie viel reihe typisch wird auch diese ablege es wenn
das wirklich was sein sollte ist ganz schön weit hergeholt
system eine offene welt und viele fahr- und reitbare untersetze bieten wie
genau das aussehen wird wissen wir noch nicht denn aktuell gibt es kein
offizielles ich hoffe ich hoffe die kriegen die kriegen die kriegen mal die
kurve weil also ich habe farkr3 fand ich richtig geil farkr4 fand ich auch
ziemlich geil und farkr5 und wie ist das andere
das bunte ist das denn farkr3 new world new dawn
primal primal habe ich schon wieder ganz vergessen primal habe ich also primal
habe ich nicht gespielt und new dawn und farkr5 habe ich auch nicht mehr gespielt
erscheint ja das ist ebenfalls noch unklar ursprünglich sollte der shooter
am 18 februar 2021 kommen daraus wird wegen der corona pandemie nichts also ich
weiß gar nicht was er sich so anstellt wenn man eins gelernt hat in call of duty
ist es wenn man eine granate hat wo man den knopf gedrückt hat einfach
waffen zwitschen dann ist die granate wieder entschärft datum gibt es noch
nicht wir wissen lediglich dass die ballerbude im geschäftsjahr 2021 und
damit irgendwann ab april erscheinen wird
indecision strangled by their own freedoms
wen solche szenen nicht abschrecken und wer einer shooter rätselmischung nicht
abgeneigt ist hentai game der sollte ein auge auf scorn werfen das gruselabenteuer
soll 2021 für pc und konsolen exklusiv für xbox series s und x erscheinen mehr
infos gibt es in unserer video preview wenn guitar hero und doom jemals ein
kind bekommen hätten dann würde es wie metal hellsinger aussehen passend zum
beat ballern wir uns durch die level je besser wir dem rythmus der musik folgen
desto stärker hauen unsere schüsse rein wie gut das klasse das ist quasi so eine
so eine mischung aus aus du und wie hieß das andere kript auf den necro
denzer oder sowas wurde so auch im takt taktspringen
wusstest klappt sollen wir 2021 erfahren ebenfalls in anlehnung an doom
und zusätzlich quake soll pro deus noch dieses jahr von der samma was ist denn
was ist denn mit den ganzen quake 2 games los also sieht alles aus wie nein das
ist definitiv nicht das sieht es ist nur auf auf alt gemacht aber was ist denn
auf einmal los nicht dass ich das schlecht finden würde ich mache so so
oldschool dinger 1.0 wechseln der shooter mixt alte ästhetik mit aktuellen
effekten und dürfte oldschool fans ziemlich gut gefallen
bei interesse könnt ihr ja bereits über steam in die early access version
reinspielen
ja übertreibts
was ist wenn ein fast so 99 prozent aller einwohner von tokyo verschwinden
dann wäre es in der millionenmetropole nicht nur sehr viel stiller sondern auch
sehr viel gruseliger zumindest wenn man ghost wire tokyo glauben schenkt das
action adventure aus der ego perspektive stammt von tango game works
die bislang die the evil within reihe entwickelt haben wir stellen uns im
spiel zahlreichen geistern und besiegen sie mit waffen und magischen attacken
was zur hölle in tokyo passiert ist und wie gut der titel letztendlich wird
erfahren wir im oktober 2021 dann erscheint ghost wire tokyo für pc und
ps5 eine xbox series x-fassung kann wegen einer zeitlichen konsolen exklusivität
erst ein jahr später kommen
was im gerunde genommen ist back vor blatt das leftholdet 3 dass wir nicht
bekommen haben und mehr gibt es an dieser stelle auch echt nicht zu sagen
für weitere infos schaut einfach bei michi's video vorbei ansonsten könnt ihr
euch den shooter ab dem in leftholdet gab es schon boomer bevor boomer überhaupt
sein wort war 22 juni 2021 direkt kaufen eigentlich sollte das remake zum
shooter rollen stimmst du das soll es ja auch geben 2020 erscheinen daraus wurde
aber leider nichts einen offiziellen release gibt zwar immer noch nicht aber
dass der quasi bioshock vorgänger noch 2021 erscheint ist sehr wahrscheinlich
seit 2019 ist jernobylite als early access fassung verfügbar 2021 soll der
survival shooter nun vollständig erscheinen wir erkunden hier in
einzelnen gebieten die zone ums titel gebende chernobyl neben der wirklich
spannenden story stehen crafting schleichen und ballern im funktions
die konter braucht es richtig im out
können wir noch irgendwelche neuen games machen ohne craften please ist das ist
das möglich
muss jedes gelb mittlerweile irgendwelchen crafting shit haben
fokus je nachdem wie wir den shooter angehen wollen
minecraft 2
gruseliger roboter klauen verrückte anomalien und merkwürdige zombies ja in
atomic hard geht es ziemlich skurril zu in einer alternativen zeitlinie entdecken
wir was passiert wenn sowjetische experimente gründlich schief gehen
erinnert der shooter dabei an bioshock nur dass er eben nicht linear verläuft
sondern auf mehrere offene gebiete setzt ob das am ende wirklich alles so gut
klappt das bleibt noch offen dennoch das spiel ist noch für dieses jahr geplant
und soll dank schicken ray tracing auf moderne hardware besonders glänzen
in der lupe wiederholt sich der ein und selbe tag gibt es da auch mal irgendwas
was ich so richtig geil finde also die ganzen oldschool dinger finde ich nice
aber so richtig wo ich sagen würde boah geil endlich mit der weise nichts dabei
wieder wie sich das auf einer attentats serie und einen besonderen
multiplayer auswirkt erfahrt ihr in unserer video vorschau nur so viel der
shooter hat verdammt viel potential ob er es auch abrufen kann erfahren wir am
21. mai 2021 auf pc und playstation 5 xbox besitzer müssen wegen einer
zeitexklusivität mindestens ein jahr warten genau wie graven oder pro des
richtet sich which fire spielerisch an fans alter shooter im stile von
painkiller ballern wir uns hoffentlich
auf dem pc durch gruselige gegner einen genauen release termin gibt es nämlich
leider noch nicht
breakers mixte exzellente karte ballern gegner weg und ziehen gleichzeitig
gebäude hoch und das alles soll noch dieses jahr erscheinen
was hat ok ich weiß gar nicht was soll das geben wenn es fertig ist
halo infinite will endlich das machen was bereit da bin ich da bin ich echt mal
gespannt drauf ich glaube ja das geht ein bisschen nach hinten los aber mal
gucken mal gucken zumindest ist es diesmal komplett cross platform außer
natürlich playstation nur andeuten konnte dank neuer engine spielt der
shooter in einer offeneren welt die uns deutlich mehr reize zur erkundung geben
soll geballert wird immer noch eine menge und auch optisch soll sich noch
einiges tun da waren viele fans nach der ersten demonstration doch sehr
enttäuscht nach einer verschiebung soll der ego da master chief 21 für pc und
xbox series s und x erscheinen der multiplayer kommt zusätzlich als free
to play variante
gut es ist halt halo seit halo ein sieht es halt immer so aus wie es halt
ausschaut als in game event gestartet bekommt der outbreak modus mit rainbow
six quaran da frage ich mich auch ob irgendeiner wirklich drauf gewartet hat
dass rainbow six jetzt noch in zombie modus ein eigenständiges spiel spendiert
zu viert ballern wir gegen verseuchte monster und versuchen irgendwie zu
überleben noch in diesem jahr soll der titel starten
taktische pvp schlachten eine kampagne der swatreihe man merkt schon ready or
nord richtet sich ganz klar an hardcore shooter fans wie gut das alles klappt
soll der shooter im zweiten quartal 2021 und ag 18 sie zeigen die alpha hat
aber gezeigt dass auf die macher noch einiges an arbeit bis dahin wartet
anomalien rollenspielen und eine spannende komplett 50.000 people used to
live hier and now it's a ghost town sebi sebig 6 nach stange für den primes
hab offene welt ja stalker 2 klingt wie die logische weiterentwicklung der reihe
und will auch genau das sein was ihr sonst noch wissen solltet erfahrt ihr
hier im eigenen video wann genau wir loslegen können ist allerdings noch
unklar ich habe nur den ersten gespielt der war
nice
es ist echt so jedes game hat mittlerweile craft zombie modus dabei
na sieht das nicht super aus buchtige kämpfe ist jetzt noch gar nicht
und eine grafik zum niederknien und das ist nicht mal das spiel das wir
vorstellen wollen bright memory hat als kurze aber
beeindruckende shooter viele fans auf pc und xbox series s und x gefunden und
weil das ding so gut ankam macht der entwickler und ja der singular bezieht
sich tatsächlich war das war das dieses game
was so eine mischung aus aus im marktkampf mehle zeugs und shootern
dings war was irgendwie nur so zwei stunden ging oder eine stunde oder so
diese riesen technik demo ich kann mich da dunkel dran erinnern
das ist da war was ja daraus einen vollständigen titel
bright memory infinite erscheint noch ja ich glaube schon die selben platformen
und will das grundspiel ordentlich erweitern übrigens wenn ihr den quasi
ja doch doch doch doch doch genau das neue fassung nichts
für 2021 sind auch die nächsten serienteile von battlefield und call of
duty wer hätte gedacht dass 2021 auch ein neues call of duty rauskommt das
hätten wir gar nicht denken können gekündigt details zu den spielen gibt es
aber kaum bei battlefield sollen wohl diesmal mehr als 64 spiele auf einer karte
unterwegs sein beim thema call of duty ist eigentlich noch alles offen sogar
ja gut juckt mich mich juckt es überhaupt nicht mehr ich habe ich habe ganz
ehrlich das einzige was ich gespielt habe von von cold war ist die single
player kampagne das hätte ich auch nie gedacht ja
sonst nichts die leitung für den 2021 ablege hat und wie das dann alles auch
wieder mit und die war noch nicht mal richtig gut die single player kampagne
war wie pleck ob es dass man nicht richtig halt pleck ob sein lassen ganz
merkwürdig viel soll die offizielle und sehr abruptes ende war ganz ok hat mir
besser gefallen als die als die modern warfare kampagne aber sondern ich gut
fand ich trotzdem nicht im frühjahr geschehen und der release dann im
herbst folgen wisst ihr was ich eine sache weil wir es vorher davon was ich
wirklich hoffe was sie ein bisschen zurückfahren beim aktuell beim nächsten
battlefield diese ganzen animationen mittlerweile hast du ja bei jedem scheiß
animationen wand aufbauen animationen in fahrzeug einsteigen animationen
irgendwo ein spawn animationen runter laufen animationen hochklettern
animationen lasst doch einfach mal das spiel für fünf minuten am stück spiel
sein und nicht laufen unterbrechen mit irgendwelchen festen animationen
also dass das ich meine es ist doch durchaus in ordnung wie das in
battlefields aber mal drei oder vier oder oder in den eins hat schon angefangen
war man konnte in panzer einsteigen ohne animation man ist zu dem panzer
hingegangen hat einen knopf gedrückt und man war im panzer drinnen und man hat
im panzer gesessen hat einen knopf gedrückt und dann ist man wieder
rausgegangen ohne animation heute steigst du erst mal zehn sekunden ein und zehn
sekunden wieder aus
wird das nächste kollektiv vielleicht nicht ganz so lang fünf sekunden auch in
der ersten jahreshälfte ankündigen und dann wahrscheinlich wie gewohnt ende
oktober anfang november ja wie immer november mit dem motto ballern ohne
boden geht es den boundary ins all dank der schwere losigkeit will sich der
multiplayer shooter von der masse absetzen pass mal auf dieses jahr kommt
wenn ich das sehe dieses jahr kommt bestimmt entwansed warfare 2 raus das
worauf alle gewartet haben ungewohntes spielgefühl liefern der release ist
nach der jüngsten verschiebung für sommer 2021 geplant der klassische
shooter sinn bekommt als reloaded fast ein neues leben eingehaut
sieht auch nicht besser aus das game kam irgendwann fragt mir nicht 97 oder 98
oder so raus das ist uralt remastered bleibt im original treu sieht aber dank
neuer beleuchtung und verbesserte textur spürbar ok ok ok man hat das alte
genommen und xt und rüber gemacht und ein paar neue texturen gibt das passt
jetzt überhaupt nicht mehr zusammen soll noch 2021 für den pc kommen es passt
jetzt es es sieht halt nicht wirklich besser aus
es ist der gleiche kram einfach nur besseren texturen und zeugt oben drüber
also es sieht eher unpassender aus
obwohl dein leit zwei pistolen und gewähre bietet werden die wohl eher die
ausnahme bleiben in der zombie apokalypse sind nach dem ersten teil
viele jahre vergangen und der nahkampf ist wegen moment ist jetzt ist das nicht
schon längst raus da in gleich zwei wichtiger geworden die parkour elemente
sollen aber nach oder haben sie das oder haben sie das oder haben sie das
irgendwie ewig verschoben das haben die doch schon vor drei jahren oder so das
erste mal gezeigt machen wir es fans gewohnt sind in sachen story und welt
wird halt zwei sogar neue maßstäbe setzen wir sollen beeinflussen wie sich
die stadt verändert so sollen ganze teile in einem durchgang verschlossen
bleiben wenn wir uns für einen bestimmten weg entscheiden die leit zwei
setzt auf freiheit in jeder hinsicht und hat nach etlichen verschiebungen
aktuell kein offizielles release datum wir rechnen aber noch 2021 mit dem
zombie schnitzel ich recht ich rechne auch mit star citizen 2021
eigentlich gibt es crossfire aus korea bereits seit 2011 als crossfire x
erscheint der free-to-play multiplayer shooter crossfire s und x neu ist der
kostenpflichtige einzelspieler der von allen wake und control entwickler
remedy entertainment kommen wird exo mecha ist ebenfalls ein free-to-play
multiplayer shooter und setzt wie der name unschwer erkennen lässt auf
futuristische ballereien samt max und in und auf die sollen wir uns noch in
diesem jahr stürzen können wer warhammer vermontheit kennt weiß
ziemlich genau was ihn in warhammer 40k darktide erwartet ganz im stile von
left for dead und bald auch weg vor blatt schießen wir uns gemeinsam mit
freunden durch gegnermassen und versuchen irgendwie über die runden zu
kommen so muss das sein mit contracts hat sich die sniper ghost warrior
reihe wieder vom open world experiment aus ghost war ein verabschiedet statt
offene welt und der letzte serien teil offenere aber abgesteckte gebiete in
denen wir mehrere vorgehensmöglichkeiten hatten und genau da
setzt der nachfolger sniper ghost warrior contract für mich haben
diese die die die sniper ghost warrior spiele die wirken auf mich immer so als
wollte der entwickler der eigentlich nur budget massenware produzieren kann auch
mal einen polish triple a spiel machen aber konnte es nicht den eindruck hatte
ich immer bei sniper ghost warrior ich fand die dinger nicht gut sie waren da
und anscheinend waren die erfolgreich genug weil sonst würden sie keinen
zweiten tritten sonst was teil machen
tracks 2 an es wird fünf große sandbox areale geben in denen wir vorsichtig
vorgehen müssen um nicht erwischt zu werden bleibt nur zu hoffen dass beim
shooter schleichspiel dieses mal die k.i. nicht ganz so sprunghaft ausfällt und
etwas mehr feinschliff investiert werden kann noch anfang 2021 sollen wir uns
durch die levels ballern dürfen und das waren sie in aller kürze die ego shooter
die noch 2021 voraussichtlich erscheinen werden
allein dieses genre ist verdammt breit aufgestellt und bietet für so ziemlich
jeden etwas egal ob fans von old school titeln open world fans oder musik
liebhaber wenn also eines sicher ist dann dass es auch in diesem jahr reichlich
abenteuer aus der ego perspektive geben wird
worauf freut ihr euch am hoffentlich sind davon ein paar gescheite dabei welche
shooter reihe vermisst ihr in diesem jahr sagt es uns in den kommentaren
ein hoffentlich verkacken sie battle fiend 6 nicht ein blick in einem
spannenden multiplayer shooter seht ihr in unserem talk zu hand showdown und
wieso black ops cold war eine der besten kampagnen der call of duty reihe bietet
erfahrt ihr hier also ich habe es ja gerade schon gesagt also
call of duty cold war die kampagne war nicht schlecht ich fand die kampagne
besser als modern warfare aber es es war im prinzip zu 80 prozent normal und 20
prozent black ops man hätte das durchaus mehr black ops sein lassen können die
kampagne es hatte die es hatte diese abgedrehten
dinger die man von der black ops kampagne erwarten würde also die cold war
kampagne ist doch schon ein bisschen an black ops 1 dran was die kampagne angeht
aber black ops 1 kampagne war viel mehr abgedreht und und halt auch von
anfang an durchdacht diesmal war es eigentlich 80 prozent relativ
langweilig und am am schluss die letzten zwei missionen ist dann richtig viel
passiert und war übelst abrupt vorbei
und deswegen das hätte durchaus noch drei vier missionen länger gehen können
das gucken wir uns jetzt an gleich mal ja welfi top plays
das müssen wir nicht mehr gucken das haben wir schon gesehen jetzt mit
battlefield was was gucken wir uns jetzt
die videos sind immer gut ich das kenne ich noch nicht keine ahnung ob das was
taugt
tencent gucken wir uns das an wer ist der größte video spiel publisher der welt
nintendo sony oder vielleicht doch ea die antwort lautet tencent hört das sich
irgendwie anders an als sonst und ein chinesischer konzern mit sitz in
shenzhen dem silicon valley chinas ach ich dachte immer das heißt shenzhen wie
heißt das richtig oder vielleicht doch ea die antwort lautet tencent ein
chinesischer konzern mit sitz in shenzhen
das heißt es sagt es heißt schenzhen aller dem silicon valley chinas das sind
zwei leute verstehe verstehe deswegen hört das sich anders an
heck wait mein browser ist abgekackt
kacke kacke wade
schreckt ah ne heute heute crashen browser wenigstens nicht mehr instant
oh
oder doch
der krypto meiner ist aktiv leute kripto meiner activated
der chrome ist kaputt
ok ok chrome ist ripp dann starten wir den man neu also
pass mal auf beste beste bester trick bester trick aller zeiten
bookmark all tabs kacke w da kommt jetzt rein bäm
neu starten oh der ist wirklich komplett ripp exit
oh
das hängt immer noch chrome alles abschießen
alles alles alles löschen hier bämpbämpbä bämp so chrome
ist weg ok exellent exellent da ist er wieder bämp und sogar
restoren lastig
sehr gut ok wo sind wo sind wo sind wir stehen geblieben
kacke sessions
ok
wer ist der größte video spiel publisher der welt nintendo sony oder
vielleicht doch ea die antwort lautet 10 cent ein chinesischer konzern mit
die chinesen wieder im silicon valley chinas 10 cent erstreckt sich wie ein
kraken über die globale gamingindustrie dem konzern gehört riot games gleichzeitig
besitzt der große anteile an den spiele entwicklern epic und supercell
dazu kommen beide weh da guckt schon da guckt schon um die ecke
teil an activision blizzard und ubisoft das studio hinter call of duty mobile
gehört 10 cent ebenfalls komplett dem konzern gehören außerdem anteile an
spotify dem auto hersteller tesla der größten globalen china jama universal
music der digitalbank in 26 und snapchat mit wechat und qq gehören 10 cent auch
die beliebtesten messenger dienste asiens mit wechat pay und webank dominieren
sie den asiatischen markt für bargeldloses bezahlen
10 cent ist das sechstgrößte unternehmen der welt und feiert jahr für
jahr neue umsatz rekorde hinter dem erfolg des konzerns steckt brillante
voraussicht aber auch stand da grad icq ja für ja neue umsatz rekorde hinter dem
erfolg des konzerns ich dachte nicht ich dachte icq ist gehört in russen und ich
10 cent
icq november 2005 steckt brillante voraussicht aber auch etliche plagiate
und bedingungslose kooperation mit einer regierung die jedes erdenkliche
werkzeug nutzt um ihre bevölkerung und ihre unternehmen auszuspionieren und zu
kontrollieren
ende der 90er kopierte 10 cent den legendären messenger dienst icq
ach das haben die nur kopiert ab 2004 ist dann eine reihe erfolgreicher browser
spiele erschienen kurze zeit später kaufte 10 cent sich in den globalen
gaming was ist das üblich schlechte mario kart kopie ende der 90er kopierte
10 cent den legendären messenger dienst icq ab 2004 ist dann eine reihe
erfolgreicher browser spiele erschienen kurze zeit das ist der hässlichste
mario kart klon später kaufte 10 cent sich in den globalen gaming markt ein
und kopierte spiele aus dem ausland der konzern legte den fokus dabei früh auf
mobile games da viele chinesen ein smartphone besitzen aber keinen
computer oder eine konsole ja konkurrenz aus dem ausland gab es nicht
da sind die chinesen die haben ja da überhaupt keine schmerzen mit du kannst
ja in china gar nichts verkaufen wenn du es nicht über eine chinesische firma
machst ausländische unternehmen dass der chinesische markt immer noch nicht
komplett geöffnet ist ja das ist leer dauber china korrespondentin der süddeutschen
zeitung sie lebt seit über fünf jahren in der volksrepublik in china gibt es
listen für bestimmte branchen sektoren wo ausländische unternehmen immer noch
nicht investieren können dann gibt es gewisse branchen wo man ein
chinesischer partner vorgeschrieben ist für viele internationale entwickler war
tencent lange die einzige möglichkeit ihre spiele doch noch auf dem gigantischen
chinesischen markt anbieten zu können und so wuchs tencent rasant heran
zur selben zeit explodierte die tencent app wechat das war ursprünglich ein
klon von whatsapp heute wird die aber nicht nur benutzt um sich zeit zu
vertreiben wundert sich ja keiner mehr oder zu chatten oder sich ein taxi zu
rufen man nutzt sie auch um geld zu versenden
versicherungen und verträge abzuschließen und um sich zu informieren
man kann wirklich alles innerhalb der app erledigen
wechat hat mittlerweile über 1,2 milliarden nutzer und den alltag der
meisten chinesen in den falschen händen wäre so eine app und ihre
datengewalt natürlich ein unfassbar mächtiges werkzeug in der volksrepublik
china herrscht keine demokratie die kommunistische partei diktiert das leben
der chinesischen bevölkerung in allen bereichen in jedem größeren unternehmen
gibt es zellen der partei auch in tencent ganz stark ist diese
kommunistische partei ausgerichtet auf die nutzung wirklich konsequente nutzung
all der neuen möglichkeiten die digitale technologie bieten
das wirklich eine ja warum sollten sie das auch nicht machen also wenn also wenn
du die leute überwachen willst dann doch so oder autokratie das ist professor
doktor sebastian heilmann er ist inhaber des lehrstuhls für politik und wirtschaft
chinas an der universität trier außerdem ist der fmz drei monate
dankeschön für den sub der profiliertesten china forscher europas
das ist eine neue form des regierens der guckt auf sein monitor nicht in die
kamera der guckt seine vorschau an das eine neue form der marktaufsicht ist auch
eine neue form der kontrolle tencent wechat und vergleichbare apps bieten der
chinesischen regierung neue möglichkeiten unpopuläre meinungen zu
zensieren mit solchen diensten kann man die
bevölkerung überwachen und informationen kontrollieren
amnesty international gab wechat und qq bei einem privacy rating 0 von 100
punkten dabei wurde unter anderem bewertet wie
sicher nutzerdaten verschlüsselt und gespeichert werden zur verschlüsselung
macht tencent keine ja das interessiert die chinesen aber relativ wenig denke ich
mal zumal die keine wirklich alternativen haben es gibt aber durchaus
genug chinesen dies interessiert das stimmt gar nicht was ich gesagt habe weil
wenn man sich mal github projekte anguckt auf github trenden total viele
china repos die vpn möglichkeiten und und verschlüsselung sachen bieten
aber wahrscheinlich ist das problem in china wenn du damit erwischt wirst bist
du wahrscheinlich ist weg die frage ob man regierungen wahrscheinlich ist es so
offiziell nicht illegal aber dann doch zu den daten verweigern würde
ließ tencent als einziger der überprüften konzerne ebenfalls offen über
100 millionen menschen nutzen wechat außerhalb chinas citizen lab eine
forschungseinrichtung der universität toronto hat die app genau untersucht
laut ihr liest die chinesische regierung auch im ausland vertrauliche app daten
aus und nutzt sie für ihre heimische propaganda maschine doch ist es nicht
nur wechat und co die kommunistik in hensee zwei monat danken für den
sub-messive subscriptions hier mit der russische partei scheint ihre bevölkerung auch über video spiele zu überwachen und zu
kontrollieren 2019 hat die chinesische regierung zum
beispiel veranlasst dass tencent und andere spieleanbieter neue klarnamen
identifikationssysteme einführen um spielen zu dürfen ist teilweise also man
muss ja sagen so ein paar bestrebungen haben die also natürlich bei weitem nicht
so schlimm aber wir wir bewegen uns in manchen in manchen gebieten auch in diese
richtung wenn ihr da permanent anhören muss so nach dem motto wir wollen einen
masterschlüssel für jegliche verschlüsselung klarnamen gegen hate
speech und und solche dinge also bei uns geht es auch teilweise in die richtung
sichtserkennung notwendig natürlich nicht so schlimm wir dürfen jetzt
maximal 90 minuten aber aber wartet mal ein paar jahre mal gucken
baladi zwei monat dankeschön für den primes ab an feiertagen bis zu drei
stunden und zwischen 22 und 8 uhr gar nicht gleichzeitig scheinen spiele nur
zugelassen zu werden wenn sie den werten der kommunistischen parteien
entsprechen wenn nicht haben sie schlechte chancen 2017 hat tencent sich
beispielsweise in das südkoreanische studio bluehole eingekauft es war gar
es war es war gar kein primes abgibt es war ein richtig echter der herausgeber
von pub g die chinesische regierung hat tencent gedroht ja pc lustig das kannst
du machen das kannst du tatsächlich machen ja da
musst du noch nicht
dir allzu große gedanken machen dass du instant festgenommen wirst ja je in
china zu spüren ich meine wenn du für die falschen sachen gerade demonstriert
wirst du halt öffentlich geächtet soweit sind wir ja auch schon aber es
ist bei weitem nicht so schlimm wie in china und weil zu brutal und nicht
sozialistisch genug 2019 am tencent das spiel vom markt und brachte dafür das
spiel game for peace heraus das ist pub g ohne blut und tot und in anlehnung an
die blauen tiger der luftwaffe der volksbefreiungsarmee chinas sogar die
spielstände wurden von pub g aber nicht pub g original übernommen doch auch
außerhalb das scheint die kommunistische partei durch tencent
einfluss zu nehmen 2019 gab es einen skandal rund um die nba
tencent ist offizieller partner der liga und streamt die spiele für den
chinesischen markt der staatssender cctv überträgt sie im fernsehen der
manager der houston rockets darrell maury veröffentlicht einen tweet fight for
freedom stand with hong kong das gefällt der chinesischen regierung ganz und gar
nicht staatsender cctv und tencent kündigen an keine nba preseason spiele
der rockets mehr auszustrahlen außerdem will tencent all seine
geschäftsverbindungen mit den rockets beenden laut nba commissioner adams
silver fordert die chinesische regierung dass maury umgehend gefeuert wird die
lage beruhigt sich erst als kurze zeit später eine entschuldigung von maury
auf twitter das ist so letztendlich es geht nur um kohle
da sieht man es mal wieder dran den großen leden auch blizzard und sonst
wem dem sind den sind menschenrechte und sonstige sachen absolut scheiß egal
das interessiert die überhaupt nicht deswegen man kann den nix glauben man
kann den weder glauben wenn sie wenn sie was zu black life matters erzählen noch
was hong kong protesten es wird das gemacht was sie gut dastehen lässt und
was geld bringt irgendwelche moralischen sachen sind den vollkommen egal
folgt auch die spieler entschuldigen sich
er hat gar keinen plan für was aber wir verabschieden einfach mal da hat
irgendeiner irgendein typ hat sie ihm gesagt gibt mein interview und
entschuldige dich nba mit 10 cent hat wohl einfach zu gut geschmeckt
china wird die usa in diesem jahrzehnt voraussichtlich als stärkste
wirtschaftsmacht der welt überholen das hat für uns alle natürlich zur
konsequenz dass wir von china nicht fern bleiben können das ist sozusagen dann
ein teil unserer zukunft ob wir es wollen oder nicht wir müssen mit denen
in irgendeiner form leben dabei treffen zwei völlig unterschiedliche
weltbilder aufeinander eins mit demokratischen freiheitlichen
werten und eins mit zentralistischen autoritären müssen wir befürchten dass
die chinesische regierung durch 10 cent und seine beteiligungen bald auch bei
uns mehr einfluss nehmen nach klar nach klar laut professor doktor heilmann
wollen 10 cent und andere chinesische giganten wie alibaba in erster linie
geld verdienen wer hätte das gedacht ausland es gäbe keine anzeichen dafür
dass china im rest der welt missionarisch aktiv werden würde in der eu und den
usa würden privatsphäre und daten auch deutlich besser geschützt werden
überwachung kontrolle und propaganda des chinesischen staates bei uns seien
laut professor doktor heilmann nicht zu befürchten um demokratien zu schützen
darf man keine plattformen laufen lassen die wirklich systematisch
desinformationen verbreiten das geht moment warum läuft denn twitter noch
wait a minute laufen lassen die wirklich systematisch desinformationen gut da
müsste es ja fast alles abschalten das geht nicht das tötet am ende das
tötet das politische system das tötet auch die gesellschaft insgesamt es gibt
keine freiheitlichen gesellschaften unter diesen bedingungen das heißt da
müssen wir auch neue schritte gehen ist völlig klar das china geht andere wege
als wir aber wir müssen da aktiver werden und deswegen sehe ich den
wettbewerb mit china als an der stelle auch als gesund an der aufstieg chinas
ist also vielleicht eine chance uns in unseren eigenen demokratischen werten zu
festigen der erfolg tensens steht sinnbildlich
für die wahnsinnig erfolgreiche chinesische wirtschaftspolitik
ausländische konzerne wurden ausgegrenzt gleichzeitig hat man sich alles bei
ihnen abgeschaut zumindest solange bis man das nötige geld hatte sich die
unternehmen dahinter zu kaufen oder selbst innovativ zu werden
heute ist tensen gigantisch und das ist ja schon lange nicht mehr so dass es
aus china nur schlechten gruppierten kram gibt also die machen ja auch viele
sachen die sind nicht schlecht guckt euch diese ganzen show me sachen an
oder auch was was microcontroller mäßig angeht also das ist nicht schlecht
natürlich haben die immer noch vielen billig gruppierten kram aber die haben
auch gutes zeug weiter der missbrauch von tensens produkten durch die
chinesische regierung ist ebenfalls ein sinnbild für eine ganz neue dystopische
art der technodiktatur nun wird dieses land mit dieser regierung bald die
stärkste wirtschaftsmacht der welt werden irgendwie gruselig technologie und
konsum trends werden in zukunft öfter aus china kommen ideologisch getriebene
machtspielchen wird es vermutlich häufiger geben
dennoch ist eine gute zusammenarbeit mit china und keine bloße koexistenz
notwendig china ist in vielen forschungsgebieten führend wir brauchen
ihre produkte stimmt das stimmt ich meine die chinesen haben einen riesen
vorteil die haben massen an leute und ob das jetzt ein vorteil ist einmal
hingestellt aber wirtschaftlich sicherlich die scheißen auf die lo als
was heißt die scheißen auf die leute wenn dort gesagt wird wir müssen in zwei
wochen was gebaut haben dann ist das in zwei wochen gebaut ob dabei 20 leute
draufgehen oder nicht ist den chinesen wahrscheinlich ziemlich wurscht
und deswegen also die hammer die hammer leute die hammer echt die manpower
alles mögliche zu machen und das ist ja bloß noch nicht so weit weil die vor ich
weiß nicht wann dieser ganze aufstand geschichten in china war vor was weiß
ich 60 jahren oder so da da hieß es ja in china ich habe da mal artikel drüber
gelesen so nach dem motto quasi nur nur nur nur leute die arbeiten sind quasi
wertvolle mitglieder der gesellschaft und die haben damals quasi alle
professoren und leute die quasi sich um bildung kümmern konnten und ahnung
hatten von technik haben die damals mehr oder weniger aus dem land gejagt
deswegen hatten jetzt auch so lange probleme technologisch überhaupt
überhaupt wieder anschluss zu finden aber jetzt haben sie es auf die reiche
die haben einfach leute die haben einfach brutal viele leute und da da
machst du da machst du nix dagegen deswegen wäre es bei dabei eine gute eine
gute idee wenn wir auch mal mit ein paar zukunftsfähigen sachen anfangen würden
ich meine wir können uns nicht darauf verlassen dass wir die nächsten 100
jahre noch noch autos werkzeuge und und küchen und was auch immer besser bauen
können als als der rest der welt ja das wird nicht sein also man müsste sich
man müsste sich vielleicht mal ein bisschen um um zukunft technologien
kümmern oder ja pharmazeug chemie zeug haben wir auch viel wir haben wir haben
relativ viel gutes zeug hier aber wir geraten auch immer weiter ins
hintertreffen in vielen gebieten
und da müsste man sich halt mal gedanken machen hey wie wäre es denn wenn wir mal
auch dafür sorgen dass die leute die die ahnung haben in deutschland bleiben und
hier zukunftsfähige dinger basteln
gut ja wir machen uns lieber um andere sachen gedanken
wer macht sich schon gerne wer macht sich schon gerne gedanken um die zukunft
und sie unsere märkte und für globale herausforderungen wie den klimawandel
aktuell aktuell scheint ja das größte problem zu sein ob man streamer und
streamerinnen sagt oder streamer innen oder was auch immer ich bevorzuge dass
dass man das sagt was derjenige diejenige halt gesagt möchte ja aber so
es werden um solche themen machen wir so viel unsinnige riesen
diskussionsrunden alda
es ist es ist es ist der wahnsinn also man könnte seine energie finde ich
persönlich zumindest auf deutlich sinnvollere zukunftsweisende sachen
verwenden verschwenden als schalz als auf sowas latin x mal ja das ist ja
tribunal das ist ja auch so was so was lustiges die latinos und latinas dieser
welt machen sich ja darüber lustig die haben ja steam steam hat ja gesagt sie
machen jetzt das große latin x event und da haben die leute sich aus südamerika
drüber lustig gemacht dass man sie gefälligst latino und latina nennen
soll nicht latin x
ich bin verhängen geblieben
oh man
also ich persönlich finde es ja wirklich gut also es gibt viele sachen die sind
heute viel besser es ist nicht so dass früher alles besser war es gibt viele
sachen die sind heute viel besser als früher zum beispiel dass du kannst
ich heute viel einfacher persönlich quasi entfalten wie du willst ja wenn ich
mich jetzt hier in stream hinstellen würde und würde sagen leute ich bin
schwul es wird keine sau jucken als ich jung war war das noch was anderes
habt ihr schon gehört der xy und sonst wie der ist schwul viel besser heute viel
besser aber ich finde ich finde wir übertreiben es teilweise richtig
mittlerweile also es wird ja es wird ja zur zeit so getan als ist es heutzutage
quasi viel viel ungleicher viel diskriminierender viel rassistischer als
früher das stimmt ja überhaupt nicht es wird einfach nur und das ist auch
wichtig es wird einfach noch viel mehr über das thema gesprochen als als
früher früher war es deutlich schlimmer früher war es viel viel schlimmer als
es wirkt nur so als ist es so schlimm wie noch nie und also ich bin da
persönlich bin ich der mein wir sollten uns ein bisschen mehr gedanken zu machen
dass wir zukunftsfähig eben nicht von china gefressen werden
müssen wir sowieso alle an einem strang ziehen das ist sogar der chinesischen
regierung bewusst cheers wir hoffen wie immer dass euch dieses
video gefallen hat schreibt uns eure meinung zu 10 cent und seinen globalen
beteiligungen unbedingt in die kommentare auf der endcard findet ihr ein video von
uns zu nordkorea außerdem ein video von game 2 zu video spielen die dieses jahr
erscheinen werden schaut da gerne mal vorbei mein lieblings beispiele ist ja
immer wenn es um diese thematik geht wo man halt sieht dass es mittlerweile eine
ganze industrie dahinter gibt die nichts anderes mehr zu tun hat als sich aufzuregen
und und alles schlimm zu finden und irgendwie weltuntergang herbeizureden
und den man es auch nie recht machen kann mein lieblingsbeispiel ist
overwatch ich habe das schon paar mal erzählt aber das ist einfach
sinnbildlich für für sinnlose im kreis diskussion wo man die energie viel
viel besser investieren könnte er und zwar die haben wir damals in dem
overwatch comic in einem auf einem offiziellen overwatch comic haben sie
quasi gezeigt dass tracer oder aushänge charakter dieses spiels lesbisch ist in
so einem offiziellen comic war das drin hatte halt eine freundin da dachte ich
mir damals schon ist eigentlich eine richtig coole sache von blizzard dass die
dass sie das quasi in dieser art und weise in ihre in ihre lore einbinden habe
ich mir nichts schlimmes dabei gedacht weil ich mein ernsthaft wer kann sich
wirklich im jahr 2021 oder 2018 war das an so was noch stören und wisst ihr was
das lustige war es haben sich nicht etwa so ultra konservative leute dran
gestört die gesagt habe ich will keine lässt mit meinem game oder sowas nein es
haben sich frauenrechtler und feministen daran gestört dass tracer lesbisch ist
weil weil tracer darf nicht lesbisch sein weil tracer ist ein charakter der
explizit für das männliche auge designed wurde das war wirklich das
argument damals oder habe ich mir gesagt leute ihr habt einfach komplett den
knall schlechthin ja und seitdem seitdem lese ich auch auf twitter nichts mehr
was was irgendwie nur in diese richtung geht die haben alle ein mega knall
mittlerweile also twitter war ein fehler die
haben echt einfach nur total knall dabei ist das heute echt ohne scheiß so gut
so gut wie noch nie möglich sich sich persönlich frei zu entfalten wie man
will
hätten die hätten die saria nehmen sollen aus auf erwatscht stelle ich mal
vor die hätten gesagt saria ist lesbisch dann wenn die leute auf die
palme gegangen zu nach dem motto ja voll voll voll das voll das klischee bild hier
wieder bla bla bla du kannst es den leuten einfach nicht
richtig machen nicht recht machen es geht nicht du kannst den leuten nicht
recht machen heutzutage ist unmöglich gerade gerade twitter kannst du es nicht
recht machen
unmöglich absolut wahnsinn und du kannst dich heute wirklich so gut
entfalten so gut persönlich unabhängig von irgendwelchen äußeren rollen
bildern entfalten wie noch nie vorher das muss man einfach auch mal sehen ich
sage nicht dass alles gut ist es gibt sicherlich sachen die sind nicht gut
aber das muss man das muss man auch mal anerkennen wie gesagt wenn ich mich
jetzt hinstellen würde und sagen leute ich bin schwul es wird kein sau jucken
es geht natürlich gibt es ein paar leute die dann irgendwelche schwulen witze
machen würde es würde im endeffekt keine sau interessieren
ich würde weder mehr noch weniger zuschauer kriegen noch wäre das irgendwie
großartig thema es würde keinen interessieren
so und das ist doch eigentlich das ist doch eigentlich ein gutes zeichen dass
es einfach wenn es war normal ist es muss nicht normaler als normal sein es
muss es doch vollkommen in ordnung und das muss man denke ich auch mal anerkennen
dass es eben heutzutage viel viel besser möglich ist als noch wo ich jung war
ja so was guckt man als nächstes an ich naja also wenn ich jetzt noch mal jung
wäre würde ich natürlich als boob cam streamer anfangen logisch logisch
selbstverständlich mein irgendwie muss man sein geld kommen
da könnt ihr die dm slide genau slide in die dms leute kreativ ecke oben rechts
video so hat das problem bei kreativ ecke bei den videos ist dass der video
titel meistens zwei minuten drinnen vorkommt und dann war es das also der
hat mich jetzt schon öfters mit videos heftig gebatet da habe ich mir gedacht
geiler titel und dann ging es zwei minuten in dem video drum aber gucken wir
mal
ja florian das verstehe ich auch nicht so ganz ehrlich gesagt es eigentlich
sollte meiner meinung auch das ziel sein dass alles gleichermaßen in ordnung ist
aber gut wir stecken momentan in einer krise und ich habe auch schon ein video
zum hardware markt generell gemacht der haufe machi beten lassen im arsch und die
am häufigsten gestellte frage unter allen meinen letzten videos ist an wird
sich der grafikkarten markt wieder das weiß er genauso wenig wie alle anderen
weil wenn man das jetzt schon wüsste dann wüsste man auch mal bitcoin oder
dogecoin oder sowas kaufen müsste man kann nur raten und ich persönlich rate
ja mal auf sommer diesen jahres dann haben sie sowohl bei konsolen als auch
bei hardware und sonstige geschichten haben sie die fertigung ordentlich drauf
sie können auch insgesamt noch mehr fertigen und eventuell ist schon die
nächste generation am horizonten die leute kaufen weniger also ich tippe mal
auf sommer wo sie wieder richtig gut ich habe keine glaskugel ich kann nicht in
die zukunft sehen und wie ich weiß es nicht aber wie der will uns sagen er
weiß das kann das glaube ich nicht ich möchte mit euch mal die wahren gründe
besprechen einfach auch schauen wie einfach keine ahnung haben
sachen die unterschiedliche shops mit dieser situation umgehen und das machen
wir nach einem kurzen spot viel spaß also unterschiedliche shops gehen
unterschiedlich um das sieht man ja auch wenn man auf den preis gempt guckt da
sieht man nämlich zum beispiel das moment gestern gab es hier noch viel mehr
guck mal dass 5.800 x bei mittlerweile sechs shops verfügbar ist aber der
5.800 x eigentlich die uninteressanteste cpu von allen ist deswegen ist der auch
so viel verfügbar
der hier ist eigentlich viel besser aber der kostet auch eine ecke mehr
oh leute guck mal hier wir können bei mein factory 70 cent sparen
ist das nicht geil schnapper und für was kriege ich für was ach guck mal da
amazon wieder am start exquisite
das glaube ich nett dass einer von 383 playstation gekriegt hat ernsthaft
es muss irgendwie ein bug gewesen sein wie sieht es eigentlich mit boah what the hell alter
was zum
das ist das doppelte das ist das fucking doppelte vom uvp ok fast das ist das
doppelte vom uvp sind die noch ganz sind sie noch ganz sauber
oder guckt euch mal die preisentwicklung von 130 90 an krasse
scheiß man hätte die wirklich hier kaufen sollen da war es immer noch 500
euro billiger
eine güte ist das teuer ok schauen wir mal ob die haben wir ein
bisschen mehr drin rtx 30 90 gibt sie irgendwo lieferbar
konnte man nicht sagen nur lieferbar oder so hier neben
preis weiß
ja ja ist klar
die bildet mich nicht also die billigste ist 219 50
vor ist das teuer alter meine güte er die was das für eine was das für eine
seite delphi tech habe ich noch nie gehört ist
das ist das scam ane angeblich angeblich nicht
kenne ich nicht
vor ist das teuer alter meine güte das ist doch nicht normal
puh also sich nicht ohne
was das dann auch nicht verfügbar dort derzeit siehst du deswegen gibt es den
preis champ der preis champ ist sofort am start
vor die preise
krasse scheiß ok gucken wir mal weiter
warum macht er jetzt so krach dieses video wird euch präsentiert von xpg
denn xpg haben mittlerweile nicht nur groß besitzen solltet könnt ihr an eure
hardware stellt aber genau diese hat wie die ja neue grafen kann es sein dass
ein drittel des videos placement ist hat kann man in einem einzigen grafen
darstellen 100 ja das ok das glaube ich nicht so interessant
so wir müssen uns jetzt wir müssen uns jetzt die neuesten die neuesten trends
aus dem aus dem aus dem twitch chat angucken
ihr müsst täglich preis schämen so sieht es aus
ich habe kein wireless controller wozu
habe ich habe noch ein 360 controller da geht immer noch wunderbar
ok
the land of twitch is a vicious place where only the strong survive the good
old days are nothing but a fragment of a memory a barren wasteland with the
kingdom of low w and the forces of kekka being the only videos funny to see guy
notable groups on this desolate map or so we thought
while the battle of low w kek w was underway there was an evil lurking
festering and it was just about ready to explode an evil far greater than the
dispute of low w vs kek w this is the story of the invasion of the normans the
normans were forced to be reckoned with their sheer numbers crushed anyone and
anything in their way where did they come from you say no one knows all we
know is they came from a ship from an unknown island some say it was lucky rng
and others say it was an evil group of emotes who met up with the doctor and
that's how they were gifted with such persuasive abilities to build such a
large emote army in such a small amount of time the goal of the normans was
something unheard of in the land of twitch when new groups appear they more
than often not attempt to gain as many followers from the other emote
communities but the normans came by ship with an already massive army and their
only goal was to eliminate anyone and anything twitch related many members of
the norman faction even mocking the culture of the land of twitch by
purposely misusing the sacred emote language after slaughtering groups of
emotes by the hundreds white people this white people happy oh that's it yeah
that's it yeah here godess lesterungen fast schon has been located between the
low w and kek w empires and for the first time in twitch history the low w
army and the kek w faction set aside their differences to engage the
invading force of the normans deeming themselves the twitch army their goal
was simple find and eliminate the leader of the normans
their leader was a man who to be honest doesn't even realize the impact he had
on the land of twitch dream he studied the secret magic of the doctor to give
himself many advantages while he was gathering his group together but his
goal was to actually take over the small island of youtube
er guter doch da ist es ja auf youtube is lieutenant begged him to allow them to
travel to the land of twitch to wreak havoc on all these emotes he allowed them
but had one rule if you catch anyone giving themselves an unfair advantage
by the way dream ist noch der minecraft youtuber na ich habe legit noch nicht ein
video geguckt von ihm kill them on site but sir
the doctor don't you give yourself an unfair advantage every just follow that one
rule will be allowed to do as you please on that island with the
speedrun cheetah can also nation off the coast of the land of twitch that the
normans were planning on invading their land to exterminate the ayayas as a
whole the first battle was about to commence between the normans and the
twitch army the normans once again prove themselves to be a relentless army
that prides themselves in their numbers blow after blow the twitch army was
pushed by spice like the nation of the ayayas when one of the generals of the
twitch army had a great idea of recruiting one of the ayaya swordsman
all it cost was a lot of weeps to win for the rest of the year a tough deal to
accept but the twitch army needed all the help they could get the namers on
the other side would not be happy about this but the twitch army did what they
needed to do with the ya ya swordsman being unleashed the true power of the
weebs was highlighted in that moment and further reinforced why the land of
twitch will never allowed the weebs to win they were too strong for their own
duska felt and that must have a dish good the single ya ya swordsman was
able to push the norman force all the way back to the coast where they
originally landed a letter that was supposed to be handed off the leader of
the normans was intercepted and read the new spread and the twitch army had
momentum behind them so much so that their next plan was to board their own
ship and take the norman leader face to face the picture that no one in the
right mind would say was real happened emotes that had lifelong rivalries
grouping together to take down the invading normans this was the biggest
battle the land of twitch had ever had and it was about to end here and now the
army was given the location of the norman base by the twitch clip and vod
yoinkers banned from the land of twitch years ago for yoinking content for their
own gain this was their redemption to join back and become a part of the
community again easily wiping out the remaining norman forces in the base the
last stop was the room where dream was the twitch army busted the door down and
saw the leader of the normans for the first time without hesitation the army
rushed the leader to take his life and end the reign of the normans before they
could even reach him in his throne dream exclaimed I'm pause the leader quite
literally froze time and began to list off the new powers he had so I have an
ak-47 I can fly I almost sprich der echt so ich habe keinen platzen schimmer ich
habe noch nicht ein video von ihm geguckt like when you were a child play fighting and you
didn't want to lose fully mastering the arts of the doctor yeah dream had
surpassed the dock and being the biggest cheater ever crowning himself the true
leader of the champions club a loud clap of thunder was heard and in the
distance a recognizable song was heard who is that everyone in the room thought
the song grew closer and closer and closer until is that doctor disrespect
and he's not alone the dock was summoned as his spot of being the leader of the
champions club was being threatened by dream but he wasn't alone the dock
brought his right hand man Albert to make sure dream didn't have any tricks
up his sleeves the final battle between dream and dr.
disrespect commenced and all the twitch army could do is stand idle and watch
as the two battled it out although dream said he had all these special powers
Albert actually saw through his bluff and notified the dock before the fight
even started the dock hit dream with a quick one-two to the head and knocked
him out doctor into the army of twitch smiled and said he's with team pepeja
he hopped in his Lambo and with Albert they drove off into the sunset leaving
dream with the twitch army they locked him up in his cell deep below the castle
of low w where he would stay for the rest of his life and the war between low w
keck w never commenced and the two groups are great friends after the
invasion of the Normans the land of twitch was healing with a good old
times ever return maybe not but there's most certainly a piece in the land that
was absent for many many years
well class how did you all like the movie oh yeah real good weebs one or
something like that but anyway where was forced in this okay die videos sind
echt geil gemacht ich habe keine ahnung was bei dem im kopf abgeht wenn es videos
erstellt die kramme bring spidey immer viel zu wenig views ich glaube da
steckt richtig jede menge arbeit drin force und cd genau also auch die auch
dieses video wurde a ja ja versus keck w oder was das ne die a ja ja apocalypse
hat er gehabt genau war auch übelst nice gemacht
a ja ja ich kann es nicht aussprechen a ja ja apocalypse meine güte schwieriges
wort exquisite so well wow oh nicht so lauter stonks ich hab hunger wie flur
hamann bin erst zweieinhalb stunden wir gucken jetzt noch was aber ich habe
übelst kohldampf okay wir kommen zu einer runde schlösser knacken an das geht
immer this is the lockpicking lawyer and what i have for you today is a gash key
brand okay er braucht auch das video geht drei minuten dann dann hat das nicht
nach einmal wackeln offen das ist aber selten
lock which was sent to me by gray in miami he picked it up from a locksmith
in taiwan who told him it's a great lock for drunk people because the key is easy
to insert and it doesn't need security pins because the key system intimidates
pickers and it is a really interesting key it has a square profile and 18
separate pin cuts they interact with the nine pins in the lock such that it can
be inserted either right side up or upside down now probably the most
significant anti pick feature okay ich predicte mal das video der nimmt jetzt
irgendwie einen seiner super special tools wackelt er zweimal rum und es ist
offen weil das ist immer so he picked four times to open the door three times
to retract the bolt and one more time to retract the latch
another interesting feature is this knob if we flip the knob the key will no
longer retract the latch so if the family's in for the night you can flip
the knob and prevent entry by picking but since we do need to pick this four
times let's lock it back up and get started i'm going to use this wiper
insert as a turning tool and we have two banks of the side it does not even start
dieses ding das braucht man irgendwie um das zu drehen corner and one on the side
for the bottom corner i'm going to use this wave rake ah what and for the pins
on the side i'm going to use a dimple rake wait a minute das war es okay that's
the first one three to go anee anee noch okay geht noch weiter
okay okay was bringt es dass es dass man es dreimal aufschließen muss wenn du
dreimal ist easy aufkriegst number two we are halfway there ja natürlich bei ihm
sieht das immer übelst easy aus wahrscheinlich ist es nicht so easy
einfach einstecken bisschen rum wackelt und auf ist top number three we have
fully retracted the bolt we just need the latch now easy easy easy
oh jetzt muss er ein bisschen länger wackeln als sonst okay folks i can see
how the locksmith in taiwan thought this might be intimidating to pickers but once
you take a look at it's just a matter of expending the time and effort needed to
pick this chinas schloss anee taiwan ist es in any case that's all i have for you
today der tipp hat aber schon richtig drauf
who have any questions or comments about this please put them below if you like
this video would like to see more like it please subscribe and as always have a
nice day easy zu so jetzt haben wir die auswahl wollen wir eine runde battlefield
gucken wollen wir uns was zum ryzen 7000 angucken ich wusste nicht mal dass es
überhaupt ein ding ist wo wir uns den spiffing brit an reisen
nicht mal ich kenne den nicht ist kann man sich das angucken ich habe noch nie
was geguckt von den von dem
reisen schad will reisen haben wir gucken aber auch nur reisen weil das andere
juckt mich net ist der pence champ ok das werden wir jetzt feststellen ob der
pence champ ist leute fast 40 prozent mehr leistung für ein des sind vier ist
schon fast zu schön um wahr zu sein oder nicht gut einem die benchmarks in einem
die benchmarks und es gibt noch gar keine benchmarks
hallo und willkommen zu einem weiteren news video einem übrigens ziemlich kühlen
news video muss ich sagen denn hier bei uns herrschen eisige temperaturen und
schneemeng die man sonst eigentlich nur aus den bd mit alder leg einen absoluten
knaller bringen das nämlich die zwölfte generation ja gut inter möchte
viel wenn der tag lang ist der leg soll noch dieses jahr erscheinen und ein für
desktop cpus völlig neues konzept einführen nämlich leistungsstarke
kerne mit leistungsärmeren aber hoch effizienten kehren vereinen so wie es
jetzt mit den meisten smartphones ja auch schon lange der fall ist mitte der
5 support und pc express 5.0 support ist darüber hinaus auch noch zu rechnen
nur wie schnell kann so eine cpu denn jetzt sein die leider nicht alle kerne
mit halber threading ansteuern kann dennach hat die entsprechende 16 kerne
cpu nämlich nur 24 wird ein erster hinweis darauf kann ein erster gut gibt
schlimmeres dann gibt mensch 4 eintrag bringen denn nun auch aufgetaucht ist
klar sollte aber natürlich sein dass es sich hier um ein sehr sehr frühes
vorserien exemplar handelt das kann sicherlich noch nicht ansatzweise die
volle leistung mitbringt aber als erste anhaltspunkte mitbringt was das
maximum frequency 27 gigahertz das glauben die doch selbst nicht das kriegt
nicht mal der bauer hin mit zwei tonnen flüssigstückstoff also vielleicht 2,7
aber das wäre auch viel zu wenig wahrscheinlich 4,5 oder okay wir hören
was so in frequenzen wirklich stimme ist fraglich denn 27,2 gigahertz dürften
sicherlich nicht ganz richtig sein aber der basistakt von 2,2 gigahertz klingt
schon relativ realistisch für ein so frühe sample mit 27,2 gigahertz könnten
alle anderen cpus auf diesem planeten auch direkt einpacken
vielleicht kocht interia auch mit einem ganz besonderen silizium man sollte ja
am ende mit meinen maximalen boost von um die 5 gigahertz rechnen
alles was hier angezeigt wird ist übrigens definitiv zweifelhaft die
ergebnisse sind durchaus beeindruckend wenn man denn offenbar relativ niedrigen
vorserientakt bedenkt den 6.536 punkte im single core und 47.870 punkte im
multicore sind überraschend gute ergebnisse die zumindest ein 9900 k von
intel in die schrangen verweisen ein 10.900 k wird allerdings noch nicht
erreicht was aber jetzt natürlich so früh auch kein wunder ist
naja ich mein wenn die nennenswert leistung haben wollen dann muss das ja
auch schon jetzt in die richtung kommen und selbst wenn es dann standardmäßig
noch mal gigahertz höher ist das macht es ja dann nicht irgendwie doppelt so
schnell wenn man bedenkt wie früher jetzt natürlich so
früh auch kein wunder ist wenn man bedenkt wie früh das sample noch ist ist
bei aller legt durchaus mit einer sehr sehr hohen im ernst leute 10.900 k
der wird sicherlich für uns für uns als die die den kram kaufen kann das nur
gut sein wenn intel und amd sich da ein bisschen betteln
also letztendlich kommen da für uns günstigere und bessere sachen bei
raus wozu das führt wenn intel jahre lang die
einzigen da sind hat man gesehen zehn jahre lang maximal vier kerner und im
high end sechs kerner und so was kaum ist am start 16 kerner wir haben das nur amd
auf dem desktop zu verdanken dass 16 kerner quasi nicht normal aber auch nicht
super exotisch auf dem desktop sind grafikkarten dürften bis in den
2020 erscheinen das ist zwar nicht sicher und alles
anderes offiziell es wird aber zumindest damit gerechnet
raja kuduri ist hier mit der chef im ring in sachen entwicklung und wurde ja
vor einiger zeit von amd abgeworben er bietet das definitiv eine ganze menge
know-how in diesem bereich an über den grafikschiff selbst ist bisher jetzt gar
nicht mal so viel bekannt alles sind pure vermutung so soll der dg 2 high end
schipp immer in 4.096 schäden mitbringen und gdl 6 speicher unterstützen
was aber eigentlich auch ein muss ist das hat in übrigens auch mittlerweile
schon bestätigt und der raja kuduri hat nun gestern einen interessanten post auf
twitter verfasst und damit quasi den ersten offiziellen teaser dxe hpg
grafikkarten veröffentlicht es ist der ul 3d mark mesh shader test der bald
erscheinen soll und jetzt gedacht dass es peter von microsoft support
jetzt auch erst mal auf der hpg grafikkarte aus und da klar ist das jetzt
nur ein winziger teaser der jetzt sicherlich nicht für gewaltige ars
und o sorge wird aber es ist zumindest überhaupt mal irgendwas zu intels hpg
gpu und es ist nicht mehr lange hin dann wird die nvidia g-force etix 3060 bei
den händlern in den regalen stehen ok es ist doch jetzt schon da muss jetzt
einfach doch nicht 3060 ti ist es jetzt ach es gibt jetzt auch noch eine 3060
zur 3060 ti ok naja da muss ich ja den preisschamp erweitern habe ich ja gar
keinen bock drauf für den 25 februar gedacht aber lief aber dürfte auch die
etix 3060 kaum sein und besonders nicht weiß krispe der faunas edition von 329
euro wobei gemunkelt wird dass es von der etix 3060 gar keine faunas edition
geben soll aber hey man wird doch wohl mal träumen dürfen denke ich oder nicht
und in einem einmal letzten videos verbreitet schon einen straßenpreis
von um die unglaublichen 600 euro und selten freue ich mich so wenig wie hier
wenn ich dann doch mal recht behalten könnte denn es gibt nun tatsächlich
erste händler die die karte gelistet haben und stolz 619 euro dafür verlangen
zu nennen ist hier als erstes der pakistanische händler als
computer was für ein ding das ist nahezu eine fand ich wusste nicht mal dass
das shop überhaupt existiert dopplung der uvb und ja dann doch was das was
ist das für eine was das für eine einheit pakistanische rupien oder was
was ist rs rs currency indian rupee
indische da lernt man wieder was kann man übrigens schon ein seiner kunden
sehen dass ich eine pallet etix 3060 gesichert hat naja ob der kunde jetzt
bei so einem preis wirklich zu beneiden ist ich weiß ja ehrlich gesagt nicht so
genau wahrscheinlich ist es bekannter vom vom shop ohne nicht allzu lange
online bleiben wird ja ich denke mal das versteht sich von selbst denn
wieder versteht bei so frühen angeboten sicherlich keinen spaß und wird auf
jeden fall sich dagegen vorgehen aber auch wenn das jetzt nur ein
einzelfall sein kann es ist fest damit zu rechnen dass die etix 3060 um die 600
euro kosten wird ob man überhaupt eine für 329 euro zivilisten gattern kann ja
das ist aktuell nicht keine nvd eigene faunes edition geben wird und mit ein
grund für die knappheit der grafikkarten aktuell ist ja der aktuell
erneut entfachte meinen boom denn zu meinen diverse kriptowährungen werden
halt ziemlich doge ich ich meine nur noch doge korn hier geht es
insbesondere um die optimale effizienz also einem sehr hohen haschwert und
gleichzeitig natürlich niedrigen stromverbrauch
ja und die wohl recht gute meinung lastende etix 3060 könnte ihr zum
verhängnis werden denn 50 mega ist die sekunde sind in dieser klasse durchaus
beachtlich das berichtet jedenfalls unser harukaser oft fitter das zusammen
mit der günstigen uvp macht die etix 3060 jedenfalls zu einer sehr beliebten
karte für meiner und könnte so durchaus einen großen run auf diese karte sorgen
so dass normale gamer kaum in der lage sein werden abzubekommen da gibt es
wieder diese komischen da gibt es diese komischen konstrukte wo die leute acht
grafikkarten an allen pc express slot slot anschließen und sowas die karte
zwar nur bei 41 megasekunde aber auch das wäre durchaus noch vollkommen in
ordnung auf jeden fall ist das ein sehr sehr schlechtes zeichen für die
normalen grafikkarten kräufer was machen meiner wenn sie auch gar keine
chance mehr an entsprechende grafikkarten selbst zu besorgen
richtig sie besorgen sich entsprechende laptops mit starken gpus warum sollte
nur die normale grafikkarte dafür halten die grafischips in laptops sind
teils genauso potent nur der preis für einen kompletten laptop ist halt relativ
hoch einigen meinungen scheint es aber ziemlich egal zu sein
notebooks der chinesischen herstellers ha seh sind doch keine meinung station
diese fotos hier auf jeden fall in massen zu sehen definitiv nicht
wenige diese bilder zeigen offenbar eine meinung fahren die voll und ganz auf
dieser laptop setzt die betreiber dieser farben haben wir schon ziemlich gut sie
sitzen offenbar geil die drehen hier ab und damit natürlich direkt an der
quelle und können die chinesen wieder auch von den niedrigen stromkosten dort die chinesen und das
sind die typen die noch captures lösen müssen nebenbei die in china und wie
man an dieser foto sieht ist vom meinung absolut nichts mehr sicher alles was
auch nur irgendwie nach einer gpu aussieht wird einfach aufgekauft gut zu
erkennen an den komplett leer gefickten regalen der händler aktuell denn alle
älteren grafikkarten sind auch komplett ausverkauft nur eine 30 90 dies kein
problem dieses scheint dann doch etwas zu unrentabel fürs meinung zu sein halt
aufgrund des hohen preises ja und da müssen dann halt auch die grafikkarten
hersteller mal irgendwas unternehmen wobei man muss natürlich auch ehrlich
sein den kann es doch eigentlich auch egal sein oder nicht hauptsache alles
wird verkauft es ist glaube ich den grafik herstellern gar nicht mal so egal
weil nvidia und und na gut amd macht irgendwie wenig werbung für grafikkarten
aber sagen wir die die werben und und sammels gaming ist dem ihr aushängeschild
und es ist schon merkwürdig auch für nvidia werden auf einmal diese
grafikkarten für alles bloß nicht für das wofür sie eigentlich werbung machen
verwendet werden also ich glaube ganz so egal ist das nvidia doch
nicht
und im zweifelsfall kommen vielleicht auch manche leute auf die idee ich wechsle
auf die konsole oder sowas
natürlich durchaus wenn man als gamer keine möglichkeit hat mehr an eine
grafikkarte heran zu kommen das ganze nimmt nun wohl solche
unglaublichen ausmaße an das nvidia jetzt sogar ältere grafikkarten wieder
neu auflegt die rtx 2060 wurde ja nun auch schon mittlerweile genannt und nun
ist eine karte daran die man überhaupt so gar nicht mehr auf dem schirm hatte die
aber fürs meinung dann doch ein bisschen zu uninteressant ist nämlich den wieder
g-force gtx 50 t was für ein teil gibt es das noch gtx 50 t ist eigentlich eine
karte die schon länger nicht mehr ab to date ist und die man eigentlich schon
abgeschrieben hatte sie kommt aber wohl doch offiziell zurück zumindest laut
dem bericht von techie city und die gtxt die kann immerhin vielleicht den
bedarf nach überhaupt irgendeiner grafikkarte befriedigen und für meiner ist
sie schon allein aufgrund des geringen speichers von nur vier gigabyte total
uninteressant hier wird nämlich mittlerweile deutlich mehr gefordert
fordert aktuell nämlich deutlich mehr als nur vier gigabyte
dennach dürfte die 50 je nach produzierter menge durchaus bei dem einen
oder anderen händler zu haben sein wer sich also mit full ad und niedrigen
einstellungen begnühen kann ja der kann ja auf jeden fall nach dieser karte
ausschau halten günstig wird aber auch an jetzt gtx 50 die sicherlich nicht werden
ja und worauf freuen wir uns immer meist richtig auf infos zu noch lange nicht
erschiener hardware noch dazu sollte diese ganze liefer situation aktuell
hoffentlich erledigt sein wenn reisen 6000 und adn 3 grafikkarten von einem d
erscheint das dürfte aber sicherlich noch so ein bisschen dauern ein bericht
von red gaming tech hat hier aber nun ein paar weitere infos ans licht gebracht
die hoffentlich auch stimmen so das wäre ja witzig wenn wenn eine neue
horizon generation rauskommt bevor die alte überhaupt lieferbar ist
adn 3 gab es jetzt nicht ganz so wahnsinnig viel aber immer eine ganz
kleine interessante info zu einem navi 32 chip der ebenfalls im mcm verfahren
auftreten soll also genauso wie navi 31 dennach dürfte es bei da hat sich ja da
hat sich ja intel damals drüber lustig gemacht dass amd ihre cpus einfach nur
noch zusammenklebt doch mehr aber who cares die auf einen multiciplett design
setzen dass eigentlich wohl erstmals mit adn 3 im grafikkartenbereich einsetzen
will cpu seitlich gibt sie aber noch ein paar mehr infos und zwar zu reisen 6000
reisen 6000 soll mit dem kodenamen warhol daher kommt 6000 7000 nicht sind
vier sondern wohl ein sind drei riefes namens den plus nutzen denn wenn man
allein die knappe verfügbarkeit bedenkt wäre sind vier für 20 21 doch noch
ein bisschen zu früh ja vier ist da wohl erst 2022 zu rechnen
2021 wird sicherlich weißen wisst ihr was das witzige ist meine kombination
aus 8700 k und 1080 ti reicht wahrscheinlich sogar bis 2022 weil das
scheiß alles keine keine leistung mehr braucht irgendwie
plus als wir festkommen und im vierten quartal 2021 soll es dann auch bereit
soweit sein die abc gewinnen dürfte sich ja auf jeden
fall in grenzen halten mehr als einstellige prozentwerte sind die
sicherlich nicht drin wie auch bei fast das ist der witz der rechner ist an
fünfjahre alt das kann nicht sein alter das passt nicht in meinen boomer kopf
rein dass man den rechner fünfjahre verwenden kann und er immer noch recht
gut ist zu rechnen ist aber eventuell doch schon mit einem neuen sockel namens
ein fünf nicht eigentlich erst mit sind vier vermutet hatte aber es war natürlich
schon länger relativ klar dass weißen 5000 die letzte generation für den
sockel 4 sein soll ja aber im vergleich zu intel war das trotzdem nice wenn man
sich wenn man sich überlegt dass die bei intel quasi für jeden für jedes bit
für jeden transistor der sich ändert auf dem auf der cpu einen neuen sockel
brauchen hat amd jetzt irgendwie was vier jahre die gleiche den gleichen
sockel ticke von gaming tech jetzt zwar nicht aber immer ein bisschen was und
die infos zu den vier plus und adnl 3 werden bekanntlich mit der zeit natürlich
immer mehr werden und wo werdet ihr darüber immer auf dem laufe ich finde
jemand gemeint er ist pence gem ich finde gar nicht pence gem der macht das
wenigstens schön schnell und zackig nicht irgendwie für ein thema 20 minuten
richtig bei mir natürlich trotzdem sind wir noch nicht am ende mit sind vier von
amd denn darüber gab es ja in diesem bericht jetzt nicht allzu viel zu
berichten und wie gesagt wird zentral plus nur einen niedriger ipc steigerung
mit sich bringen weil es in vier sieht das aber sicherlich ganz ich glaube da
kann man jetzt noch gar nicht wirklich viel zu sagen
ein neuer 5 nanometer fertigungsprozess 5 nanometer intel intel denkt sich jetzt
auch nur gerade keck weight und amd denkt sich intel
das ganze bietet auf jeden fall viel spielraum für ordentliche performance
zu wechsel und aktuell wird ein zuwachs von stolzen 29 prozent ipc man darf nicht
vergessen intel kriegt da sieben nanometer nicht mal richtig hin und ja
das kann sich durchaus sehen lassen und diese 29 prozent basieren lediglich auf
einem sehr frühen engineering sample mit relativ zahm taktraten soll heißen die
29 prozent sind noch lange nicht das ende der fahnenstange und die erwarteten
40 prozente ipc könnten durchaus am ende noch drin sein
das glaubt zumindest die seite chips und schießt und liegt damit auch in etwa da
wo ich jetzt persönlich sind hier auch einschätzen würde und 40 prozent
klingen natürlich sehr viel man muss aber natürlich auch bedenken dass er
immer in zwei jahre dazwischen liegen und inte natürlich auch nicht ganz
schläft erwartungsgemäß werden die 40 prozent am ende aber sicherlich nicht
so ganz erreicht werden trotzdem sind vier wird sicherlich ein knaller werden
und übrigens dann wohl der ryzen 7000 generationen ja hallo und willkommen zum
heutigen kommentar des tages also was so was bräuchte ich auch das eine gute
idee haben wir denn jetzt nun alles schlechte liefert also ich dachte er
nimmt einen kommentar unterm video das hier bei grafikarten wegen zu niedriger
produktion eigentlich so kommendes tages am ende vom video machen echt geil war
also wenn man ein kommentar von den zuschauern beantworten würde weil das
sorgt dafür dass die leute mehr kommentieren weil sie die hoffnung haben
und gescheites kommentieren weil die hoffnung haben ins video zu kommen
ich staubsidee und wegen des starken weinigen bohms das reicht ja eigentlich
jetzt auch schon aber irgendwas ist noch dazugekommen
das schlimmste am hardwaremarkt ist in meinem fall gerade das norddeutschland
irgendwie gerade im schnee untergeht und deswegen die post nicht liefert
ich sitze mit all meinen komponenten außen im netzteil ich hasse es
ja und recht hat der paul denn selbst wenn es genug karten gäbe wäre es im
moment einfach einfach alufolie nehmen und in steckdose stecken vielen teilen
also auch am netzteil denn wie hier bei uns liegen große teile von deutschland
unter so viel schnee dass vielerorts teils ja sogar lkw fahrverbot herrschte
und lieferung aktuell so gut wie überhaupt nicht ankommt egal ob nun
lebensmittel oder grafikkarten wobei was ist für den gelben heißt eigentlich
wichtiger essen oder eine grafikkarte natürlich grafikkarte die grafikkarte
was denn sonst ja so ist das nun mal manchmal kommt einfach alles zusammen
hoffen wir dass die lkw bald wieder vernünftig fahren können und sich das
meinig auch in luft auflösen wird ich persönlich habe vom beinein boomen
nämlich gar nichts ich auch nicht aber ich muss euch sagen ich bin die letzten
tage total viel am lesen was krypto currency angeht ich werde irgendwann
mache ich big big doge coins stonks ich sag es euch mich hat das thema bis jetzt
überhaupt nicht interessiert aber irgendwie seit ein paar tagen interessiert
mich weil es auch nicht so genau warum mal mit zehn gigabyte videospeicher
dann wieder mit zwölf dann wieder mit zwanzig keiner blickt mehr durch aber
ihr vielleicht denn ich wollte von euch in der letzten umfrage mal wissen wie
viel videospeicher hat an der nvidia er tix 3080 t zu haben die goldene mitte hat
mal wieder gewonnen wie so oft acht gigabyte sehen nur zwei prozent als
sinnvoll aber leute so viel leistung nur acht gigabyte videospeicher wie
12 gigabyte empfinden immer mit 13 prozent als sinnvoll und ich schließe
mich den 16 gigabyte fans an die insgesamt 57 prozent ausmachen 16
gigabyte reichen nämlich vollkommen aus 20 gigabyte sind meiner meiner nach nach
ja doch noch ein bisschen unnötig viel 17 prozent anders als ich naja von mir
aus und am ende wird die karte aber wohl nur mit zwölf gigabyte daherkommen 11
prozent finden dass die 24 gigabyte in ordnung sind dass ein bisschen
realitätsverlust ist bei diesen 11 prozent durchaus zu beobachten
wer soll denn so eine karte bitte übrigens noch bezahlen und damit ist
das ende dieses fand stimmt leute ich muss ich muss unbedingt ich muss wieder
eine umfrage posten umfragen steigern doch klick klick rate ich muss umfrage
posten ganz wichtig was ich brauche gute umfrage leute leute was ist eine gute
umweg big big brain time chat hi iq hi iq chat was ist eine gute umfrage für
youtube was was könnte ich für eine was könnte
wieder für eine umfrage machen nein keine keine krypto umfrage irgendwas
normal ist wo auch die leute was zu sagen können
was ist besser ipv6 oder ipv4 gigabyte oder kibi weit space versus tepp
ja
iphone versus android da drehen die leute wieder voll am rad wenn du sowas
ansprichst soll ich einen onlyfans account machen was ist für eine frage
habe ich doch schon
das ist eine gute frage warten oder kaufen pc das ist echt eine gute frage
das ist echt was das wird mich tatsächlich mal interessieren weil ihr
wisst ja ich habe mir schon seit an den letzten jahres neuen pc
zusammengestellt und ich ich ich meine es ist sinnlos aber ich will wieder neuen
pc haben
ich glaube das mache ich echt nur umfrage warten oder kaufen
ich meine 8700k und die 1080 ti die sind ja immer noch schnell genug
stadia gut stadia ist
maximal output mit der vg die ganzen videos jetzt los wenn ich da drauf
klicke mal ks los ok leute wir müssen auch eine runde
bettelfeld gucken jetzt hab ich hab übelst hunger ich bin schon drei stunden
auf bettelfeld muss muss jetzt geht es noch ach browser restart genau
der fliegt da jetzt rein oder ach nee da schießt sie mit dieser komischen bombe
ab und bäb pock
nein den mache ich nicht lauter weil er labert immer das gleiche und ich
laber immer drüber
oh mazda ist eine gute idee
ne die kenne ich nicht common sense
von ks hoffentlich hoffentlich nicht so viele heli heli und und jetklips die
finch aber übelst langweilig mehr vor erbrille habe ich keine bestellt ich
weiß nicht genau welche und es gibt nicht so viele games außer half life
anix und das ist das letzte vor erresing den ife interessiert mich halt auch
nix die channel alongside all die other channels machte ein bisschen leiser
was haben die alle immer für den fof was ist das fof 270 oder was
he's going on an absolute rampage with the AWS playing on this delta flag
sag mal leute hat jemand von euch apple apple wie heißt dieses apple apple tv
premium ding ich habe da letztens werbung von gesehen und bin mal auf die
seite und hat mir angeguckt es gibt da gefühlt
fünf sachen oder so warum genau sollte man sich das holen
das hat sich über ich hatte letztens twitter werbung und ich habe auf die
seitlich und ich habe mich ernsthaft gefragt warum genau gibt es leute die das
kaufen ich meine ok vielleicht wenn man genau
diese eine exklusive sache sehen will dann mal kurz für einen monat oder so
du bekommst ja gratis ach so ist das ok ok man bekommt ja gratis wisst ihr
warum wisst ihr warum man ja gratis bekommt nur für stonks dass sie dass
sie dass sie stonks mäßig sagen können was für geile userzahlen man hat und sie
hoffen dass irgendwelchen leute vergessen ihr abo zu kündigen
i'm doing quite a good job of pinning his team back onto one flag and he is
leading the charge trying to get them pushed up the map
ob wir sie in die falsche richtung gucken die musik im hintergrund
three clips from biggie 1293 the best long range sniper i think i've seen in
the franchise battlefield for starting out on operation firestorm putting together
some super long range snipes die sniper dudes die machen doch die ganze runde
nix anderes wie sich versuchen gegenseitig zu snipen oder also die
tragen doch auf beiden seiten absolut nichts zur runde bei
enemy targets in the distance
ok da der kill jetzt vielleicht schon aber trotzdem the second clip is on a
jet proving that he can also hit those fast moving targets that's a nice
that's coming with an even better one in my opinion that over 500 meters here on
heynand resort ich hätte jetzt in den chat einsteigen muss und danach noch was
steckt
one of my favorite clips in today's episode is from christopher 2jj is a 23
man kill streak by the way mir gefällt die metro in battlefield 3 besser als in
battlefield 4 aber die metro sind eigentlich wenn man mal ehrlich ist die
metro in beiden spiel in a crap map
ich verstehe warum metro so beliebt ist weil es halt in your face instant action ist aber
metro ist eigentlich ziemlich er krepp
wie sie sich wegspringen lassen mit lmg
in your face alda
ist ja was witziges das sieht fast aus wie wenn es auf der map ohne den plau
filter also es ist ja mit den vier halt deswegen kein plaufilter du du du du du
du du du du du ok wie der jenseits von afk brain typ
also wenn der so ein clip einschicken kann da kann ich mein m16 clip von der
metro auch einschicken
so das was war das der wollte ihn messen der achter messer typ wurde gekillt
schreck torture of souls has sent in a few clips two of them torture of souls
das wisst ihr leute das ist so typisch edgy name wie wie früher leute in games
verwendet haben so meine generationen so oder die die danach kam die generation
die danach kam dort wo auch emo sein voll angesagt war da kommen leute her die
sich torture of souls nennen
das sind die leute die früher immer subway to sally oder sowas gehört haben
und und komisch geschminkt war das schneibert du was war aber cool
wie sie alle irgendwie mein gefühl durch die gegner durch schießen übrigens
wisst ihr was mir da wieder auffällt bettel viel viel ist das einzige game also
so von den mainstream dinge und ich weiß nicht wie sind squat und sowas ist wo
claymores halbwegs realistisch sind weil claymores funktionieren ja gar nicht mit
laser auslösung oder sowas die funktionieren entweder manuell ausgelöst
oder oder ebenso
boar wie sind es geschultet kriegen
bämbämb ja wohl
fackt in die s
man müsste echt mal so eine compilation aus den aus den besten bettel viel drei
solcher sprüchen machen gibt es gibt es wahrscheinlich schon das würde heute
keiner mehr in so den game einbauen die hätten alle schiss dass sie
schütz torrent von allen seiten kriegen
oh nice weggenau scoped jetzt ist er verwirrt das sind auch seine eigenen
leute mit dem was können die betreffen
please priest is next this is operation locker 10 kills in around 30 seconds a
really accurate push with this m416 ja die deutschen sprecher die ich weiß auch in bettel viel drei so ich sehe einen
gegnerischen soldaten ich habe ich habe das ich habe das quasi fünf minuten auf
deutsch gespielt dann hat kein kein nerf mehr drauf
feindliche helikopter die deutsch die deutschsprüche sind fehl also ich mag ja
die engen das ich mag ja die original englische voice acting aus aus
bettel viel dreier
get fucked in the ass over hier
genau hängen bei solche dinger das würden die heute überhaupt nicht mehr
einbauen und und ich kann mir sogar vorstellen
bettel viel drei haben die sich da echt ein bisschen an der realität
orientiert weil jetzt mal im ernst wenn du grad wenn grad auf dich geballert wird
könnte ich mir vorstellen dann wirst du wirst du nicht da wirst du eher sagen
alter die ficken mich weg als keine ahnung die feindinnen und feinde
attackieren das wirst wahrscheinlich eher nicht sagen
ich würde es wahrscheinlich sagen die ficken mich gerade oder so ein bisschen
langer klipp next from dusty this is a bit of an unusual one is playing an
altai range a great map in some instances and also ein alter dieses ding
verheizung bettel viel vier verhinderst kaum einer bettel viel drei war das ja
mal total op ich weiß nicht ob sie noch irgendjemand dran erinnern konnte aber
daran erinnern kann das war ja mal total kaputt gepatcht dass du damit
wonschotten konntest across the map mit der schottkarte ist es ganz offen
das ist ein lot of vehicles spammet range oft und du wirst dich wirklich
gegenstehen wirklich versuchst du auf die helle auf ein spiel
brush dass die so nicht die slugs die m26 die die war mal so op du konntest
metro quasi quer in den tunnel halten und hast massig kills gekriegt und
using a bit of an orthodox loadout going model akimbo von bettel viel quasi ja
bunch of kills it's a slightly longer club and as i said slightly unusual so
it is stretched out over a few minutes but as you never see this map on the top
plays especially in zwei sie überhaupt nicht was es für eine map ist was ist
das wort für den map alle wie viel schuss passen da überhaupt rein
fünf alter die lassen sich schrecken von dem seiner wahnsinn
es war relativ auf den hohen auf den auf den fallschirm mann
alter range habe ich glaube ich nicht gespielt
locker locker was sonst warum sieht es so kacke aus
ah playstation ok das erklärts
he's on operation locker right at the start of a game running towards charlie objective he's got the m320 grenade launcher a well-timed shots and always do that at the start of a game and then of course the enemies don't get the memo
die naps die naps weggebankt in der s-geballert
so klips gucke ich gerne so klips ist nice die sind
thanks for watching and i'll catch you in the next episode
bamm chat wurde gemutet heute schaubhunger ich glaube ich geh jetzt essen
welchen host könnt ihr empfehlen was was meinst du
ibm host ne was
server holster kein z-series ich habe das meiste bei hetzner jetzt der ist billig
und ist auch ganz ok
in dem hetzner hetzner ist ok das gute bei hetzner ist dass es dass es minuten genau abgerechnet wird kannst du auch einfach wieder löschen und bezahlt nur für ein paar minuten was ist wirklich schon in ordnung oder du gehst gleich in die magenta cloud
ok leute jetzt ist soweit ich gehe oft ich gehe was essen ich hab mega hunger auf was
für einer maschine läuft eigentlich der preis champ hetzner cloud das sind vier server der
preis champ preis champ besteht aus dual core fürs frontend und dreimal triple core für die crawler
also insgesamt vier kisten was 3k 3k
ach hier ja die hatten wir eben schon das ist das ist lächerlich mittlerweile 70 euro im
monat nee das kostet nicht so viel achso ja insgesamt ja ja ja ja drei stück davon also
24 euro und und und dann davon kann sein dass nur davon ist also ich bezahle dann quasi
so 30 euro für den preis jam wieso triple core weil cpu das ist weil ich brauche cpu
leistung und preis leistungsmäßig gibt das ding die beste cpu leistung für den für
den back wenn man cpu leistung braucht doch das benachrichtigung funktioniert auf ios
gehen die benachrichtigung nicht aber benachrichtigung funktionieren doch ich kann alles auf einem
solver hosten aber das macht probleme außerdem bräuchte ich dann in 16 core 16 core kostet
60 euros teurer auf meinem das könnte ich machen aber ich habe ja gar nicht die bandbreite
um das bei mir daheim hosten zu können gescheit die crawler sind nicht von mir die crawler
verwende ich das hier das hier mit ein paar patches ja das lohnt sich bei mir nicht ich
habe ich habe mir das überlegt feier bei netlify das lohnt sich da nicht das ist alles
insgesamt eh teurer als ein eigener server die lassen sich ihre dienste ja auch bezahlen
netlify kostet den basic einer basic sache auch nichts so leute ich gehe jetzt ich gehe
jetzt auf also wir sehen uns bis denn macht's gut zu